There's got to be other explanations. They're all acting dick
whipped right now and I don't I don't understand it. Like what
is he doing to the women in the bedroom? Listen, I don't know.
And I don't think about it that much. Okay. I know. I know. I
know. But this is not the Lauren is not the first one. And she's
one of many that he, you know, stuck and they flip the out because
they can't have him the way they want him.
Yeah, I know. Sometimes it can be mental, not always physical.
Thanks for the correction, Zena. I didn't I didn't know that.
Oh boy.
Uh, Turkey Tom wants to come on. I'm guessing he wants to get
a little mad at me. It's Turkey Turkey Tom. Okay, turn this up.
I I don't What me What could he do? I agree with Zena to a certain
extent. What could he do mentally to make this to make all these
women flip the out? And I mean they flip out like
like these women, you know, there's a thing called DW and PW.
And like these women are like DWS
all the hell. And I I just don't understand it. I'm like, it
can't be that good, honey, to to when you start acting crazy
like this. I maybe just maybe it's possibility
that in Lauren case cuz I can't
speak for the rest of the women is that Lauren would find this
a huge W if her and Destiny were a couple where they were actually
an item. Like that would be a huge clout boost for her. And since
it didn't happen and he turned her down, she took that personally.
like how dare a man turn me down. And two, like that was a chance
where she, you know, she couldn't handle it and she it it [__]
it up to the point where like now what I'm going to do, this
is the only larger large streamer I know that I can basically
hook up with cuz she can't hook up with anybody else. So I hate
I'm sure she can figure it out. Hey guys, how's it going? Hello.
Let me see if the cartoon was put on here yet. Oh, it's not.
Hold on just a sec. Uh, it's going decent. Um, I've had a really
easy start to the night, so that's good. I was just curious if
you've seen any of the Destiny documentary yet. I was curious
as to your thoughts. Uh, I've watched the entire thing
already. I thought it was fantastic. Yeah, absolutely. I'm glad
you liked it. What uh
you just if you don't mind me asking cuz you and Destiny seem
to be close in height. I'm 5 foot 10 and a half. So, he's like
five I think he's like 5'8. Honestly, I don't think he's that
short. No, he's not. He's 5'8. He's not. Yeah. Yeah. I was like
uh a little taller than him, but he has like a very large forehead,
so it kind of looks strange, you know? There's like a He has
like a He has like a tall head. Six. He's not. I think he's 5'8.
I think he's 5'8. He's like a I thought he was I lit I literally
thought he was 5'3 before I met him. Like I thought he was going
to be really short. Did you Did you watch a tree? Did you see
any of the documentary?
I saw I saw only half of it. What did you think of that? You
two have very good chem. You're you're very jokey, but he's also
jokey, too. Yeah. I feel like we almost got along too well. I
don't know if that hurt. Yeah. Like brothers, as a matter of
fact. It It's uh You guys don't even know each other that long,
right? No. No, we haven't. No. Yeah. You guys act like you've
known each other for years. Yeah. Well, we just we bond over
racism. Okay. Oh, all right. That's what I'm all here for. Unfortunately,
you guys don't show that part, right? Yeah. Exactly. Literally,
you're like the uh you're like the one molecule that prevents
the other molecules from joining.
Literally. Literally. Cool. Uh hey, I get passes, by the way.
I don't know what you're talking about. I appreciate that. Just
Doug, what were some of your uh your favorite moments? I guess
I'm sure stuck out to you. Yeah, the overall theme that you basically
did kind of you kind of painted him as the um really emotionally
distant borderline psychopath with some of the stuff about his
like friends and how not even his story like didn't totally line
up which makes sense because it was like 12 years ago and he
went through like the Molina stuff and kind of turned it back
around to show him as like a human being with human emotions,
right? I don't know. I just thought like the that overall arc
of the story was my favorite part of it. Yeah. Yeah, I was trying
to uh I was trying to ask some of the hater questions like about
Nathan or whatever. I was trying to uh you know uh I didn't want
it to be just a glazing piece, although I think it probably came
across that way anyway, but I wanted it to to ask some serious
some serious questions, you know, about uh about his past, present,
and future. And uh just, you know, I mean, like with the Nick
question or whatever, stuff like that. Just like stuff that somebody
who's critical of him and hates him would want to know. Um was
there anything you didn't like about it? Was there anything you
thought was like bad or I don't know, did interviews go on too
long or I I did point out at least once. I mean, in terms of
uh things I'd maybe change I didn't love that the the long interview
like the long interview with you guys on the couch was filmed
entirely from somebody holding the camera it looked like. Mhm.
Was that like a choice you made or did you not have a tripod
or I'm just curious? Uh we just didn't have a tripod at the time.
Yeah, basically. So that's that's cuz we were handheld all day.
So you didn't have a problem with the length of the interview.
you just would have preferred that it was fixed angle more. I
thought it it probably dragged a little bit, but I didn't think
any of the like it was one of the things where I was like, "Oh,
this is all good." I thought all the questions and how quickly
um he was able to answer and just how it flowed. I thought that
was all good. It just it was almost like a podcast that was dumped
into the middle of the video. So like the weird for the pacing
of the overall video, but I I didn't think there was anything
that could be cut from that interview that was like bad or unnecessary.
So, go ahead. I don't know how you I don't know how you'd handle
that. I'm not a video editor, so I I guess maybe you're uh you're
somewhat biased in that way, though, obviously, because you and
I even me to an extent are very curious about Destiny lore in
general and all the details and know a little bit of backstory.
So, um obviously we are particularly interested. Maybe the general
audience wouldn't be, but it's it's hard for me to tell. I have
to gauge that a few weeks out to see uh how people feel about
it overall once it once it reaches a wider audience. Um, but
uh yeah, who uh my bigger question I guess for chat would be
who do you guys think I should do one on next? Uh and it can't
be a Destiny Orbiter or someone like that. It should be it should
be someone outside of the realm of Destiny cuz I think I've uh
I've probably done enough on that. But I'm pretty curious who
would make a good
uh I don't think he would do it. I don't think I'm famous enough
for that. What What did What did you say, Zena?
She said,
"Oh, okay. I have a suggestion, but I also need to before you
leave, we have to ask you about Lauren de Lagona. Okay, that's
what we have to ask you about, Tom. Oh my god. People saying
people already did Sam Hide that's been done. Um, I know you
have a Shane Gillis video, but if you're famous enough for that,
I would go I would try to do that. I don't know if you're What
do you Yeah, that's uh that's that's one where uh the Turkey
team is working on, but with the comedian guys, they're kind
of like mainstream celebs at this point. They're not really YouTube
people, so
it's kind of tough to get them. Someone said Sneo. That's a good
one. Uh Sneo actually would be quite interesting. Uh I wonder
someone just do like a 100 hour on that guy. Yeah, Gokaru did
that. Yeah. Yeah, but you could Yeah, but doing like hit pieces
and stuff on Sneo will never get old. That's like the That's
the Obviously you would say that Zena. Geez. I I love Sneo.
I know. That's what I'm saying. Hey. Wes. Who is Do you mean
Wes by the way? Is that who you guys are? Yeah. Say hello. What's
popping? What's popping, shorty? I am. Nothing much. Oh, swear
to God. I'm blushing.
Damn. How you been? I've been good. Good. I can just hear the
power in your voice. It shakes me to my core. Really? It does.
Just being in a like even a voice channel with you, I'm shivering.
I couldn't imagine standing next to you. No, you're not. Hey,
Zena, shut your mouth. You wasted
she's a waste like a beat up piece of trash. I mean I'm just
calling am I a beat up piece of and I muted out the window. What's
popping tree?
Nothing
Did you see Did you see the documentary between uh Tom and Destiny?
I'll be honest. I would rather myself than watch a documentary
about Destiny. Well, I think you have to do it then because you
just presented those you just presented those as the only two
options. So, I think you have to keep yourself now. Was it like
super politically charged? No. No, it's I haven't finished watching
this. I'm going to reserve my final documentary. It wasn't biased.
Like, it's not like this piece of blah blah blah. Uh, no it wasn't.
Tree Tree, go ahead. Finish what you were just saying. Uh, yeah.
I'm going to wait till I finish. But no, no, Wes, it wasn't bias.
Well, that's good then. Most of the time when YouTubers make
[__] like this, it's always like, uh, here I wasted
six months of my life to tell you why I [__] hate.
It was an in-person documentary. Oh. Oh, that's cool then. That
being said, I think I should do a documentary about how fat you
are, how small your dick is. I think that'll be pretty good,
right? I've gained.7 in in the past 8 weeks. Thank you very much.
Oh, you've been julking.
No, I'm down 34 lbs in 7 weeks. Well, 8 weeks. No, no,
yes. And I'm working out five times a week. You're probably going
to die. Good. I'd rather die than be obese. This [__]
is gay. That's actually base, dude. Why are you being fat is
so cringe?
Sick of this [__] dude. Got to the point where my
I felt like my boners weren't strong anymore. I think it was
fat. And your boners weren't strong cuz you were fat. I think
I swear to God, dude. My last experience was the most I've ever
had in my life. really bad. I thought I thought they said I thought
they said uh I thought they said fat guys can lay pipe. Save
some of your Save some of your fat so I could use it for my BBL.
Uh I don't know who told you that, but No,
it's just fat just covers. It's awful. It's like you're constantly
has a cloak on and you cannot take it off. I want my cloak off,
bro. I want max. So, what are we So, what are we going to be
looking at for measurements by the time we're we're fully down
to like I think like seven plus seven and a half. Wow. Not too
bad. 22 to 5.2 and like 30 34 lbs and I got at least 100 more
to go. Now, when you get there, are you going to be are you going
to have like it's not going to be like a fat sag over? You're
going to have like the sort of like a Dude, you're going to do
a documentary on me for assaulting just numerous women. I'm just
going to go to the streets and just start just in
you're you're going to go gorilla mode. I'm going to go a Okay,
I'm just kidding. No, it'll just be cool. Uh because you can't
say ape mode. What do you mean? Why are apes racist? What are
you wearing? What the No, I'm just saying in the animal kingdom,
women are to be conquered. You know, some may say true. Consent
doesn't exist in the animal kingdom, aka the best kingdom.
So far off the rails right now. What is your question about Lauren?
About Lauren? Well, one first question. Did you Did you intend
to just show that Destiny had a different girl in every different
setting you guys were at? No, they were just there. They were
just there. Okay.
Didn't want to cut them out or anything. All right. I mean, uh,
yeah. I mean, it didn't really make sense. I feel like that's
Isn't that a perfect illustration of his life? Yes, it is. But
I feel like that's the most I feel like that's the most destiny
thing of all time. Yeah, dude. She was like, uh, but towards
the end when we were filming, she was like, "Leave. You need
to go." And I was like, "Jesus."
Uh,
and also, did you see that she lost her? Did you see that she's
gone? She is threatening to sue him now. No. What documentary?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I filmed that like a like a month and
a half ago. Yeah, we were just covering all of the where she
was like, "Yeah, yeah, we just covered all of it." Um, it's not
great. Well, I guess that's that's also the most Destiny thing
of all time. I wish I knew that going into it so I could have
covered that in the in the in the video cuz that would have been
epic if I was like, "So, the girl he was hanging out with also
just went crazy on him." Yes. Did you shoot that in December
or shoot January? Um
uh
it it was all in January cuz it was like January 6th to 12th
or something was when it was filmed cuz it was like the the first
filming day was the six of the uh of the memorial. It was the
Alex it was the Alex debate was right right the the Zero Hedge
awards debate. Yeah. Perfect. All the filming was uh it was just
over the course of like that week and then at the end of it I
left Miami. So yeah, it was uh it was pretty interesting. I did
notice though after you know Lex Freeman blocked me on Twitter.
I'm not sure what's going on there. Why?
I don't know. Probably cuz I like the video of Sam Hyde. You
like the Sam Hyde tweet? You like the Sam Hyde tweet? Yeah. I
mean, it was an epic It was an epic video. You can't deny it.
If someone made that about me, I would have to I would have to
retweet it because it was just so funny. Yeah. What What can
you do, dude? AI is going to be a problem. Well, I think according
to Lexi, uh, someone else manages his Twitter, so someone else
has got the block list. He's he's too famous to manage his Twitter.
Is he? No. Which is possible. You don't know that. Possible.
So, what has Lauren been saying? Well, I think Lex said that
apparently. What has Lauren been saying? She's saying that um
she's saying that Destiny is uh that he records phone calls secretly
and that's a felony. That he hasn't had his vehicle registered
and that's another like crime. And she wants to make the police
aware of this or some something like that. Talking [__]
about everybody behind. Yeah, I haven't I have no idea about
any of that, but who cares if his car isn't registered? Like,
why is that her problem? That seems like such a weird thing to
point out. Uh yeah, it is weird. Should we go back? She's really
coming out with with everything. Yeah, doc on her phone. Just
all possible crimes. He He rolled through this stop sign. I I
reported that. So apparently not. He did roll through every stop
sign. He sped around at 180 m per hour in downtown Miami. He
killed multiple children on the way. They were all It was awesome.
Yeah, that's all I'll I'll release that soon. That'll be in the
extended cut. Yeah, get that to Lauren De Laguna. Okay. Did she
uh You know what? That's fine. She said that I had a weak jawline
and she said that I look like the guy from Blink182. So, I think
she deserves to get [__] That's an insult. Okay.
Well, okay. She was saying it in an insulting way. I don't look
like she was saying it. She was calling me emo. Okay. She was
doing it in an insulting way. She was trying to destroy me.
Dying breed if you're emo. She thinks I look like Tom, which
is the guy in the back. That guy. She told me that. She told
me that Destiny and Irelevant were talking about me during the
canvas being mad about me like terrible. Yeah, but everyone talks
about you, Zena. Yeah, that's what I told her. I was like, to
be honest, I can't see your screen anymore. I'm kicked out. Oh,
did I? Yeah, I moved, didn't I? Oh, no. Wait, but when we were
hanging out, she said Destiny is is her goat. Like, she literally
said, "Destiny is my goat. He's the greatest of all time." She
said that. Did you right after?
No, I just kind of turned back to Korean barbecue or whatever.
Uh, so she said explicitly on the stream though, just real quick,
she did Desessie did say explicitly on the screen on the stream
that they were friends, everything was good, and then basically
she wanted to be the new Molina and he was like, "Nah, I'm I'm
good. I'm a free agent." And that's the new uh the new like open
relationship
hoe. Yeah. The the new bottom. Yeah.
He'll stick to monogamy now after the show. No.
What? Yeah, definitely, dude. Definitely. That's going to happen.
When's he going to learn? When's he going to learn? I don't think
monogamy is the problem.
Monog say monogamy is not really the problem. I'm going to go
ahead and say it. I'm I think it's the women he choose to be
in a polygamous relationship or an open relationship with. Yeah.
But Tree, what's what's harder? Managing one crazy or 10 crazy?
10 crazy. That's what I'm saying.
One really here's the real strategy. Okay. When I date girls,
what I'm going to do is just date I'm an incel right now. Okay.
When I do date girls, I'm going to date a hund of them at the
same time. So when one of them accuses me of and then the rest
all accuse me, nobody will know what the truth is. So it's like
cuz there's too many claims to watch. So it's like it can't be
real. They're all It's a genius strategy. You can't call yourself
an incel if you can get girls, Tom. That's not how that works.
I am an incel. Eventually I'll get girls, but I am an incel.
Wait, being an insult is not Yeah, 100% you can be an incel like
I just realized. Wait, what about uh what about Rose? Tom, are
you not going to hit up this Rose Adamucci? You look like you
were in love when you were reacting to her stuff, bro. No, I
did not. Bro, you did. You kind of you were you were saying the
words were not matching the looks in your eyes. Okay, we can
bring it up and review it on stream. I'm just saying you had
you had a look. Incel. I don't have any. You had a look. Okay.
I'm a gay incel. I don't like girls, dude. I mean, after that
documentary, I'm starting to believe it.
literally,
Tom, go to Thailand with me. I'll change you, babe. You go to
Thailand, dude. That That might be dark. That sounds really dark.
It's I mean, it's hot. It's pretty sunny. What do you mean hot?
Cuz you guys I'm ask one guy. You mean lady boy? I mean, I keep
getting the debate of this. Does it count if they're lady girl?
Sorry. No, lady boy. Yeah, lady. They've made a Fisher Price
instead of having a Is it still gay? I feel like that drastically
reduces the I think it is gay. No, you said post up. They cut
their into a Fisher Price. Oh, well, it's still I feel like it's
still just I mean it's a bit suck. It's more gay than a naturalb
born women, but it's way less gay than a lady boy with a [__]
I mean, I agree, but like why not just have sex with a woman
with a vagina? Because if you're in Thailand, you got to try
it once. Just like you got to go to a ping pong. Are there women
in Thailand, too, though? There are like 90% of the women I have
in Thailand are women. But I one lady boy, but a posttop lady
boy, no cop, so I couldn't get over. How did you know? Did they
tell you were like I am Lady Boy?
Well, when I choked her, her Adam's apple cut my hand. Oh god.
Jesus Christ. That was a pretty good sign. Well, no. Wait, not
choke in like a murderous way. What the You never compressed
a bitch's neck? No, I I haven't I haven't I haven't compressed
I haven't compressed a guy. Murder reference. I'm not John Wayne.
You choked out. You choked out a dude. Well, he ced, so I win.
Did you really? No, it's impossible. They can't come. By the
way, you're trying. Wait, hold on. Okay, let me get Let me get
this straight. Let me get this off because you can't come anymore.
You [__] Let me get this straight. You're trying
to make the other person that you're having sex with come. That
seems crazy. No. No. I'm never trying is actually super gay.
The female orgasm is a myth. You say every now and then I don't
think it's a myth, but I just think it's, you know, to make the
woman feel pleasure. That just sounds a bit It's too much work
for it to be worth, right? What layer of irony are we in? I can't
like What is What is the irony? Okay. There's There's no irony.
I'm being completely serious. What's the study measuring women
is through vaginal penetration like 10%. I mean I think a lot
of them can if you're me because I'm uh No, I saw a study that
it's just a big gay woman can climax doing it's
I think it should be I think I I think it should be written in
the literature books that if you make a woman have an orgasm,
you are gay. Okay, then I'm a flaming
I don't care. Oh, you make him come, dude. Oh, you're cool, dude.
You make him come. Someone someone in my chat points out that
we just watched you choke Destiny. By the way, Tom, you made
Oh, not me. I just choked Darius. There's no evidence for that.
That didn't happen, dude. I I think it's literally in the documentary,
though. You're You're making more false allegations than Lauren
de Lagona. Am I? I didn't Darius, but Darius is funny. I kind
of like Darius. Did you Destiny? No. Do you dudes ever? No. No.
Men Women only? Just no one. Really? Well, like who what do you
jerk off to? I know. Jerk off. Lion Wes. He has women. I don't
have a Yeah. What do you think of like whenever you think? I
mean, I guess I I guess I could have a but I won't allow myself
to see it, you know? Yeah. But you've got to at least get a boner.
There's certain I mean I get I get a sometimes I'll get like
a feeling that I have a boner, but I never look inside of my
pants to see the boner because what you're seeing on an example
when you feel that way. Well, I see like a large bulge in my
pants, you know, cuz I've got another presumably, but it's but
it's sort of a it's sort of a Schrodinger's thing
penis, bro. Well, it's it's gay to look at your pants. So, you're
the question. I'm an insult. I told you what instigated me to
not look at it. Schroinger. I don't know. I feel like you're
a big gooner. I feel like get to the point where they like are
ashamed of it. So then they start acting like
I'm literally the biggest edger in the world. And I'm not But
I'm anti being gay and having is gay. I feel like you're jerking
off right now. I feel like it's one of those just at any moment
has nothing to do with Oh, he was quiet. He was quiet, Wes. I
think you're on to something. Can we move on to a different subject,
please? Okay. Sorry, Thomas. Oh, yeah. Let's go. Uh, if you guys
joined the presentation here, we've got the Rose Adamucci video
up here with Tom's reaction. Oh my god. I can't see it. I can't
see it. Watch this. I'll I'll restart it. I'll restart it. I'll
restart it. Is this like an intervention
drugs? There you go. Bro, this girl was cool. She talked about
doing shrooms in this video. I don't even know what that means.
Shrooms. You don't know what doing shrooms means?
She's like Steve Bushimi's Let me Yeah,
Can I come back in? Maybe it's me, right? Oh, hold on. I think
I know what it is. Okay, let me see here. Maybe I have to do
this. Meow's uh I'm trying to baiting you. I got to use the gay
community for money. I can see it. Thank you. Okay,
yeah, I was I honestly at some point I was just like, dude, it
would be less gay if they just kissed when you guys were in Walmart
like flirting super hard was uh Dude, okay, that was not happening.
That was you.
I saw that clip for like 2 seconds earlier when I opened justical
stream. That was you, Tom. I was not flirting in Walmart, dude.
Okay, you're not an incel. You're just gay, bro. I told you it
wasn't an
You're a cotton. I have gay demons, but I'm trying to ignore
them. And you guys, are you based on that Walmart video? You're
trying to let him. You're fly, buddy. I'm surprised you weren't
like encloded in a pride flag, you [__] Well, Walmart
is a romantic place. Really? A romantic place. One time I'm going
to Walmart, I see a shirt that says God hates on it. I don't
know how you feel very
[__] You know, a lot of people will say that uh what
is forbidden is tantalizing, you know. Oh, that you want to in
the Walmart and just have the bigots around you just threatening
to hurt you. That is kind of hot. I like that. And then Jack
Doerty walks around the corner and it's like, whoa,
I like it. That's a Walmart in Texas. I would not take that risk.
Okay. All parts detects are very safe because everybody's got
guns, you know, so no one's shooting because everybody knows
if one person shoots, they all shoot and then everybody dies.
Yeah.
Um maybe we don't have to go over this. Tom, what does this girl
have to do to become the person you're looking for? Would it
be not be Italian and not be loud? Let's say if she responds
to you, would it be better if she went way over the top or would
it be better if she was like if she showed that she could like
restrain herself and just was like I think the best I think the
best sign would be if she deleted her entire internet presence
and then sent me all of her money in her bank account and then
I would be Who is this woman? That's definitely not going to
happen. I said on my stream that I wanted to uh I said in one
of my streams that I wanted to hire a female to be a commentary
channel that I would write and uh I would just like script it
because women are can't do anything right. So, I would script
it and then I would uh basically just have her be the face of
it. Well, just be a YouTube drama, but there would be like a
cute girl. So, you know, so I think people would like that. I
mean, there's been a few in the past that have that have done
this, but uh they tend to get lazy or then they like, you know,
they people will find out they used to have like a black boyfriend
or something like we just can't deal with this kind of thing.
That really ruins it. It does tend to ruin it for the audience.
And so I think we need to have a uh we need to have like a QT3.14
goth girl who is simultaneously based but simultaneously has
an only fans. Well, she doesn't have to be a neo-Nazi. She just
has to, you know, say it. Is that who this woman is?
This woman is This woman applied for the position, but uh I declined
her. She's Italian. Let's be honest. It's not that white. What's
wrong with Italians? Let's be honest. She's too loud. Just listen
to the video. She's too white. She's not submissive enough. Listen
to the video.
I need like a uh a woman who's like seemingly submissive but
is coping.
stream today and you want a girl who you could turn into a commentator
while I'm
See the problem with her also. She looks like she's always drunk.
Yeah.
Yeah. She might be drunk in this video, but she just her voice
just seems like she's always off. She's got drugs. He is just
olive oil in her veins. Yeah, bro.
That just is dripping parmesan. No, thank you. Now, come on,
Wes. Be honest. She has that crazy awesome energy, doesn't she?
No, she has that crazy I'll cut your She to be clear. To be clear,
she looks The problem is not
The problem is not that she's like unattractive or something.
The problem The problem is she 17? I said she looks 17 to me.
I said I said all applicants need to be 18 and above. So, I assume
she's 18 and above. Did you check her ID? No, but I doesn't check
ID.
Just listen to her talk. You You'll in I did not message her.
Just listen to her talk. Money. I need a girl who's more interested
in the money so she doesn't have an ego attached to it. She doesn't
want to be like, you know, I want this to be a commentary channel.
I'm sorry. They don't. They literally don't.
People in my community want this to be a commentary channel.
Okay. There's no way. When you can reason with me if you want.
You can try to argue with me, okay? You can call in and disrespect
my opinion, but I know what it needs to be in my mind. And this
girl is not it. This girl is not it. Unironically, it should
probably be a girl that looks like the dog girl. Oh my god. For
the
button, what are you doing? This girl is I don't She's just I'm
talking, dude. I literally I had this idea like a couple months
ago. Daddy alert. I can fix you. You can't. She seems kind of
crazy. I mean, look at look at that smile. Look at this. This
dude's in love. Okay, I can see it. Off, bro. With that type
of haircut, I don't think you're in a position to be like choosy.
Don't think it's a Christmas tree. What do you mean by that?
I'm choosing her for my business. I can choose whoever the I
want. Tree, you kind of look like if Justin Bieber had Down syndrome
but worked for Disney. No. Are we just Are we just roasting Tom
now? Is that what this is? I was just Fine, fine. Fine, fine.
All right. Let the obese guy
I literally I did shroom. Okay, she's talking about doing shrooms.
We can't have drug addicts doing this. I mean, not that she's
a drug addict, but I can't I can't have this girl be a drug user.
Okay. Have you seen how popular she was? I mean, she was popular,
but she's a different kind of Italian. Semi Asian like the the
Jesus. I'm trying to get like a a screen capture of her eyes
when she like pops them out. Like, look at that.
[__] up, bro. That woman's got demons.
Not the gay demons, Tom. She's got way worse ones. Like, this
is very dark, don't you think? You keep This is the false accusation
demon. Well, no, no, no. She has her me too written for you already.
Are you ready? She has a septum piercing, too. I mean, she looks
like Italian Katie Bugs. Like, come on. Sorry. But when I say
when I say she has her me too tweet ready. When she when I say
she is ready, I think she has a knife ready to stick in your
kidney. She is Italian. They don't write letters. I would honestly
prefer that she that I get stabbed than anything else. Honestly,
I would much rather be stabbed than get exposed for fake salt.
That sounds way better. the why don't I just send you her video
that you're
I can see the video. I got link the video first and then some
barely schizophrenic my channel watched all of her content and
messaged me. You're pausing it so many times. Okay, I promise.
Or rather, I'm pausing it so many times. I'm not really pausing
it. I want to kiss my own ass, but I'm a cute girl. I can be
funny. Look, dude. Look at your face, bro. I'm reacting. What
do you mean? She's egotistical. Okay,
look at him,
bro. Stop. I think that's the face of more like you're not funny.
Women aren't funny. No. Yes. Base. It can be both. It can be
both. That's just reality. Okay. It can be that I'm in love with
you as well, I think. So, yeah. This is a video from
YouTube. I also watch your videos literally all day every day
because I can't not have YouTube on and I've been on YouTube
for I don't even know how long. Literally since I've remember
I I have the knowledge. I have the knowledge to be a she's the
knowledge. I just look at her hands. Look at how Italian she
is. She doesn't have all her nails on. I
I commented on your Instagram like eight times because it's She
did do that. She did spam me saying, "Let's make some money together."
Like promise. Okay. No, that's crazy.
And if anybody's going to fill the role that you're looking for,
I can do it best. I promise. Oh my god. Give me a chance. I've
wanted to be. Also, part of the problem is like I want a woman
who is not like addicted to the internet, but is but like looks
like she is. I also want a woman who doesn't have opinions. I
want a woman who doesn't have opinions so I can write them for
her so she doesn't seem stupid. But this girl is like, "You don't
even got to write it. I'll just give you all the money." And
it's like, "No, that's that's too much." She's motivated by clout
and attention and wanting to be like a member of the community
more than money. I need a girl who I can Andrew Tate contract
to give her 10%. I take 90. Like this is just too much. Like
she's going to get upset about it. She's going to want money
later on. She's going to file a lawsuit. It's going to be a whole
mess. Okay. She can have the only fans money, right? Like she
gets she gets famous. She does the only fans. She can have the
only fans money. She can have the only fans money. But this this
girl is just too she's too Italian. Okay. Tom, look at my stream.
Okay, tell me you see it, bro. I couldn't figure out who she
reminded me of. She looks like this little kid from Vine transitioned.
Why can't I see this [__] Yeah, I guess so. Do you
remember this kid? It's literally him with his Yeah, I mean I
I I agree with you, but uh what the Okay, sorry. Deep cut reference.
who you're talking about. Wes is talking about this kid apparently.
I don't quite see it, but uh he's bringing up a child on stream.
Yeah, it's like it's like this child except Wes would this one.
So, it's basically the same thing on this channel. I'm not Okay,
before taking Tom at his word, just to call, do you know who
Summer from Fish Tank season 2 is? Yeah, he said he said that
was too crazy. He said that was too crazy. Summer summer does
have the perfect look for it. But yeah, she's a little too nuts
cuz she she after she got off fish tank, she claimed that Sam
Hyde somehow like owned the hospital and was like hiring the
hospital to like [__] with her. Like it was just
too much. She's crazy. She's she's schizophrenic, paranoid delusion.
Uh you know, Summer has her moments though. You know, she's a
very uh special girl. But uh yeah, no, not for this stallion.
be a commentator because there is not there isn't a cute girl
in there with different w the hands are really going like it
is wild
fake nails on and she's moving her hands like the guys from Dead
Space like it's
thing that you said about that I look at how close she gets to
the camera said the same exact thing there needs to be a girl
in there look at that face dude no way look at that bro
[__]
look at that. What do you think happen when you get involved
with that? I don't know. I trust me, I'll be checking in with
you in like 3 to 6 months to know what happened. Okay. I'm literally
never messaging her in my life, dude. I'm not as [__]
If you message her, if you message If you send her a message
and you two hook up, do you understand how much That's not happening.
I'm not destined
off of you. You just accused me of being gay and now apparently
I'm going to this girl. Let's stop. You're saying no, though.
Tree just saw your face when you were watching her video and
now she's convinced. Why does she not have a nail on her right
pointer finger, but she does on her left? Yeah, that's what I
said. She has I thought it was a coke nail, but it's not. She's
just like them on randomly. I'm saying it's like some up Italian
[__] Like she's drunk and falling all over the place
breaking her nails all the time. Well, her look look what hand
has no nails on it. Her right hand. So she's she's right-handed.
So she's probably probably been like very rough with her right
hand. I think I think she had to put nails on that hand. I think
she did this video halfway through doing her nails so it's an
extension. What do you think with her right hand? What do you
think she's doing with her right hand then? Huh? What did you
say? What do you think she's doing with her right hand? What
do you mean rough with her right hand? You know, you know what?
You know what I mean? Oh, really? Wait, I don't. There's no way
in the middle of painting her nails. Her right thumb is chip.
You're I didn't say painting. I said putting them on. I said
putting them on. They're like a makes no sense. Look at her right
thumb, bro. It's You don't even have to write. It's been there
for a long time. I can She got nothing on the right hand at all.
Bro, she got nothing on the middle finger either. She looks weird.
Her hands look like that. Her hands look like a That's what I
said. I said she has not She has no nail on her middle finger.
She has four nails on her left and no nails on her right, which
means she's been very active with her right hand. What do you
mean by active? What's she doing? You know what I mean? You know
I don't know what you mean. Tree. Tree. Do you have nails? Inel.
So why don't you elaborate?
I had a girl. I had a girl. Yeah. What are you doing with Is
are you fingering your Is that what you're talking about? Oh,
it has nothing to do with Are you Are you jerking men off?
Um, no. It's It's something a more violent um more stern, more
dominant, more people. Yeah. It's when women domestically abuse
their spouses for watching. If you saw this
Instagram, she beats the out of her, man. That's why she I'm
so scared of her. She's powerful. I think you need to screen
share and open your Instagram DMs with this girl and show us
that you didn't DM her back. Okay, I did not DM her back, but
I cannot screen share my Instagram DM. Oh boy. Yeah, a likely
story. Okay,
I don't need to see them all. I just needed to see this girl's
DMs. But all right, we're supposed to believe it. Okay. Yeah,
you got to believe it. Okay. All right. Yeah, man. Back to Lauren
de Lagona. I think it's uh I think it's wild that she was telling
you you have to leave. She's not the perfect sweetie. Well, the
implication, I think, was that there was something something
nefarious happening. Yeah. Something was going down. It was better.
You're not. She's going down in an earlier round. She was going
to get dark. She was going to get dark. She was going to go.
Have any of you all seen the movie Basic Instincts? No. No. Never
mind. All right. Wait, so what movies? What was the impetus?
Like, so she wanted to be the new Molina. Destiny was like, "No."
And then she just goes haywire all of a sudden. Yeah. She was
going haywire on everybody. Did you see Did you saw the Hunter
Avalone thing, right? Where he like got shot at by his new girlfriend's
like ex. Yeah, that was crazy. Okay. She messaged him that day,
the day that the shooting and happened for an interview on her
channel and she was like close friends with him and was just
like, "Yo, are you okay?" And then in the same like same time
stamp as he as her asking, "Hey, are you okay?" It was like,
"I know this is like maybe insensitive, but could we do the first
interview on my channel for this?"
Crazy. Has she talked publicly about how she's obsessed with
this court case? Which court case? I don't know. Someone she
knew that was falsely accused or something. Something with the
police department. I don't exactly know. Boston police or something.
I don't know what you're talking about. She wouldn't shut up
about it. She She wouldn't shut up about it. She doesn't really
shut up at all though, does she? No, she doesn't. She goes and
goes. I thought she was nice in person though when I met her.
She wasn't like she didn't seem evil. Uh, yeah. A lot of crazy
people are like that. I guess they can fool you. Okay. I've met
a lot of them. She fooled me. You'd be surprised. I thought she
was going to be the perfect sweetie. Always
uh weary of a woman who never shuts the up. Uh,
you just advocate. Are you just
or No, I'm just saying that like there's some women who talk
talk talk talk talk talk talk. She is one of them. Um not the
only one, but it's like you know I have ringorm. Where'd you
get it? The doctor says the share that. Well, I thought you should
know you I can tell you the cure for that. You want to know it?
I already know. They gave me this cream I rub all over myself.
But tell me what the [__] cure is. What's the cure,
Tree? I'm not going to tell you now cuz you already got cream.
What do you mean you're not going to tell me? There's a better
cure. Don't you think I should know? It's climbing down my arms
to my hands. I'm going to
look. Hold on. I I kid you not. Wormwood
and and clove.
Wormwood.
Okay, guys. I don't want to chill for very long, but I haven't
chilled once this stream. Okay. Like, go. I haven't chilled once
this stream. Fill up the bars so I don't have to chill. Worms
voodoo, bro.
Haitian magic, dude. Literally, it's not a pestilent mortar,
[__] smokes flaring off. When I went to Louisiana,
I met this woman called the voodoo bone lady, and she was telling
me about like all this crazy [__] In Louisiana are
crazy, especially cinjun people. They're Hello, Darius. What's
up, Darius?
What's good, [__] Mixing black people and fringe
people just makes people weird. What's good, Wes? Are we going
to dim or not? I'm not picking you up and taking you to
like I don't want to sit in a threeman round every time I do
a lift. It'll be fine. It'll be Dude, you need rest by the way.
You're like fat as like it'll be like I go
you don't even talk to me. Okay. No, I'm not losing weight. I'm
not your daycare person. Okay. Like 300 lb. When you have like
a one big lift, you need like at least 40 minutes of rest. you
whenever you're like I never take more than two minutes in between
any set. You're lying to me. 40 Wait, 40 minutes is insane. 40
minutes is like powerlifting. Like
max, dude. You're big as a mother, dude. Literally, look at a
picture. Look at Wes, by the way, by the way. Turkey. I know
how fat he is, but I feel like no one needs 40 minutes. You need
40 minutes. You're lifting too much. Exhaust. Yeah, I'm exaggerating
a little bit, but he le needs 10. At least I need two. Okay.
Okay. No, I don't. I'm What? This is I pick less than anyone
else. Everyone else sits on their phone and yaps forever. That's
why these go to the gym and do 45 minutes of work in 3 hours.
I hate those people. I get 15 to 18 sets of like 80 to 85% max
done within 40 minutes every time. Oh, we don't do that. Let's
just do it tomorrow. We'll do a stream. No, I don't want to know.
That sounds so gay. Hey, you can meet Missk. Give like a thumbs
up and I know Misk personally. He says hi to me every time I'm
there. Bro, why are you name dropping, dude? You're just You
just name dropped Msk. No, I didn't. Like, I would be impressed
by Misk. He didn't do that at all. Is M's gym nice going? Blah
blah blah. Yeah, Miscus is a sweetheart. Uh oh, the gym is really
nice. Yeah, it's like a powerlifting gym, which Do you know who
Boss Man Jack is? Boss Man Jack? Yes, we know. Have you guys
seen the video of him losing $5,000?
I've seen him lose more than that. I watch him go for like Thank
you very much for the donation and lose it all with There's this
one really good uh edit someone made with like music and that's
like really epic. Uh [__] It's called like Boss Man
Jack like
uh starts with $70,
gets to 5,000 and then gets to zero or something like that. I'm
trying to find it, but it's like really really funny. Uh but
I I can't find it. Hold on. I'm going to go through my history
on my computer. Uh okay, wait. I found it. I found it. Okay,
just so can you bring this up on stream cuz this is like fire
content. This is like an emotional roller coaster this video.
This is going to this is going to titilate you. Wes going to
titilate Wes. I love gambling, bro. Wes, let's please go to Marlo
for real. I like I just want to go. Okay, then Uber Uber.
Can you have a car? Can you drive? He doesn't have a car and
he can't drive. I can't drive in a motorcycle or like a bicycle.
Why can't you drive? Why don't Why don't you have a car? It doesn't
matter why I don't have it, bro. I just I have a It doesn't matter.
It does matter. I'm just saying that it could be like really
cool if you picked this all up and we got like a pool together.
Like it's saving the country or whatever, right? Like we're having
like a mint like Elon or whatever in there. Like we can go stream
it. That's what I'm saying. Wes, so pick us up. We can go together
to be lit. Uh I told you I'll do it, but you're cameramaning
my stream the whole time. Yeah, man. You have no problem. I just
need to do a couple like uh I'm I'm on Yeah. So I'm unironically
on a Sasuke Yuchia workout, so I'm just doing Oh, no. What? It's
called the Sasuke workout. It's created by a guy named Nick.
Yourself. It's okay. You're just Did you really just name drop
an anime as your workout routine? Not name dropping. That's not
name drop, dude. You name drop Misk. That's not name dropping
naming. No, except you brought up and I brought up Miskf. You
named an anime like it's a workout. It is. It's based off his
body type. And I repeat, kill yourself. That's the case. Isn't
his body type in the cartoon though? Okay, I will pick you up.
You also wear a Naruto headband during the entire workout. I
have no problem with that. You're such a f slur. Okay. No, I
lied. I'm not picking you up. You're jealous. I You're so cringe.
You're scared. So cringe.
I'm not scared of you. I'm not scared. Didn't I put you in a
chokeold last night, Darius? I could have done the same thing,
but I'm nice. Oh, could you? Yes. I've been through I've been
with Big Woman. I can put something.
Darius, you need to chill, bro. I watched this dude curl Abby.
That one girl that lives with you like she was nothing. Okay.
For a body shot, he just like curled her up. You get folded by
Wes. Okay. Did you not see the clip of me and him last night?
Uh I did not. Oh, someone linked the of me big and Darius. Hold
on. We got to watch this boss man Jack clip real quick. Let me
see it. Let me see it. They do. Pika. Oh yeah. Rakeback. You're
right. And affiliate money. $26 in rakeback. Holy [__]
This is literally $2. This is like a Darius story right here.
Merry Christmas experts everybody. Oh, holy crap guy. Look what
just happened with my rake back. You got a full screen in this
one. So everyone pressing the play button cuz in this video he's
constantly being like, "I'm out. I'm out." And then he like his
body just presses the play button for him. Like he can't help
himself. Okay, let's all The worst part about this is this house
game he's playing is the worst odds of any house game. Say we're
going to make it back. This is actually champ.
Let's go. Holy [__] Oh my god. We're back. Let's
do a big 50. Come on. Big 50s.
Come on. Hit by 500. Yeah. Thousand.
Go. Let's go.
Where you at now, rats? I don't hear you. Huh? Hey, saggy lady.
Where you at? I'm a little sad. What? What? What were you saying?
You're crying now, aren't you? Oh. Oh my god. Eight times on
100. I'm about to make me another rack, dude. Come on. I'm going
to do a big 154. 156 156 I would stop right there. I wouldn't
even go any further. Go chat. Let's go chat.
Go chat. No. Oh my gosh. You just don't stop. I think Oh, three
racks.
Oh my god, dude. Holy crap. I'm going to do 300. Risk it. 300
risk it. I got to this. Hold on. This is in real time, by the
way. He's gone from I believe $26 or something to 2,200 in a
minute and 43 seconds. Okay. I would have Oh my god.
And you can see the amount he's wagering. He keeps just wagering
300 300 300 like it's nothing. He literally will like make 1,000
bucks and wager it all instantly to get the next hit. One more.
One more. All right. Get out of there. Gather. Gather. Gather.
He says get out of there and keep pressing. Oh my gosh. Down
to 150. Down to 150. Stop.
Last one then. Last one. Last one. Last one. Oh no. He he got
1,200. This is how gaming condition works cuz he keeps saying
last one and then finally on the last last one he gets it again
and he keep double it up to 300 again. One more. One more. One
more. Last one. Last one. 300. Dude, come on. You guys realize
this is an everyday occurrence for people like me. I know, but
this is normal. But yes, this is not that crazy at all. This
is literally every Darius stream I've ever watched, but with
Clinko instead of whatever this game is. Okay. So, I turned $20
into 290,000 and then I lost it all down to 30K and then made
it all back. I almost Oh my god. I almost lost a [__]
house off of $200 almost though. Oh [__] You just
can't You ended up keeping the 30 in the end. No, I chased the
30 into like two like 300,000 or something and then I then I
sold it all. Okay. All right. So, you got 300k? Yeah. So, Wes
is big on gambling overall. No, that was just this that was just
in January. Lifetime we don't talk about that. You're not able
to stop Wes. It's It's like you're just Oh, it's crazy. You have
no idea. Yeah, this like I said, this what I'm watching here
is like pretty standard, bro. Cuz I'm assuming he's in for probably
multiple thousands. He lost it and he's trying to chase uh even
or winning from his rake back and he gets a little break. Yeah.
Yeah. I've done that too. I've 10 $10 and 10k from rake back.
It's like it's gambling cope and then one out of a hundred days
it works out but then it's never enough so you keep going chase
it all and then it's zero. Yeah. Every day, baby. Listen, he's
up good right now. 3,900 bucks he just won. Let's see how it
goes. Dude, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. I can't
look at this, bro. I'm like I'm getting the edge again. I've
been off gambling for like two months and you guys I'm leaving
here, bro. I ain't see Darius. He's serious. He's serious. He's
not joking. I have watched Darius do this exact thing like a
hundred times. You know what's the worst thing for Daryus? He
had a deal, right? So, he was paid to gamble. Now he has no deal,
but he's still addicted to gambling. So, it's way
How much money being paid from stake? I've heard that boss ran
Jack was making he claims to be making 8 to 11k a week from gambling.
Yeah, I get 14k a week at about 200 average. Is that is that
money to gamble on kick or is that just money to your pocket?
That's money to gamble through stake. Yeah, keep I keep up a
month is my current deal. That's 14k. Oh, you can only keep up
to 30k a month per month. Yeah, that's the new deal with stake.
But before that, Gambdom was two day 2k raw a day with no limit.
Yeah, I switch when I switch to stake. But still, 330k a month
is easy when they give you what what's 56 grand a month. It's
easy as to cash 30. The deals, the gamma deals are so you feel
invincible. It should be. Yeah. But I'm guessing like half of
the gambling deals they give out, the people don't have any way
of controlling themselves and they just spend all of the money,
right? So the more money they give you, the worse your addiction
gets, right? The bigger you bet. And then when you run out of
your Phil money, then you put in your real money, right? The
money that you earned, then you lose that at a way faster rate.
Gambling deals for your stake deal. Exactly. It just turns people
into worse gambling addicts. It's no one that has a deal is like
living good or anything. They're all disgenerate pieces of [__]
They all lose everything. It's interesting. I didn't know it
was going down like that. Okay, we have to see boss man Jack
go down the Okay, we can't we can't stop at the wins only. We
have to watch the whole thing. One more. One more. One more.
He's up to 500 bets now. He's out 250 bets. He's out. I'm done.
And he keeps going. Oh, there you go. 5k again.
500 here. The anxiety
idiot. Gambling 500.
Come on, dude. Come on. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. 500. 500.
Come on. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Last one. Last one and last one. Oh, come on, man.
Come on. Last one. We should had a last one counter. Come on,
man. Oh, no. Stop
He's doing 500 bets now. 250. Down to 250 again. He's literally
already down to below 2,000 in like 10 seconds. Please, man.
Please, dude. Went to 500 again. No.
Oh my gosh, guys. Oh no.
I just had five. Oh, there we go. Oh my god. He got back to 2K.
He got back to 2K. Oh my god. Give me back. I love the music
change. Give me back. Give me back. The music change. Give me
back. Give me back. Yes, dude.
Oh no. Oh no. I'm 500. Wish me luck. Oh my god, dude. Oh no.
Stop.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, dude. He's talking to steak. Oh my god, dude. Oh
my god. I just lost $5,000.
Oh my god. It's over. It's over now. They're actually doing it
to me, man. Oh man. I tried to help that $31. Come on. Give me.
You have no idea how bad this is. Dude, by the way, there's not
a worse feeling in the Oh my gosh. I've got to get up big and
then lose it all. Oh my gosh. No, bro. I felt a lot of awful
things in my life. I've never felt anything like that before.
It's You feel You hate yourself so much. Click on this clip.
This next one I sent you is shorter, but it's it's just after
he loses and he's like $300 his dad gave him to gamble and it's
just his reaction basically. Yeah, he like steals money. I'm
so sorry, Gab.
The background of this clip is a really He steals money from
his parents. He takes loans from his viewers that he never pays
back. This guy's like literally Jesus, dude. Look at the wall.
That's the addiction. That's why everyone gives him. He's like
the perfect example of what a real gambling addict is like. someone
without deals, even though he has one, right? They lose everything.
They'll over their family. They'll over their friends, over their
viewers, into oblivion. This guy, I'd say there's a 95% chance
this guy ends up blowing his head off. He's kind of I mean, he
kind of looks like he's
I know that. The disturbing thing about this is that I feel like
you would fully admit that you're also a gambling addict. So,
I don't know what you're saying about yourself here. Are you
not
myself? Jesus Christ. Okay. No, not really. But I I'm good at
managing. This guy never stops. Yeah, that's what everyone says.
I'm good at managing it, but this other guy is worse. You know,
there's people are better, right? There's non-addicts that promote
gambling and just get paid infinite, but I'm no boss man, Jack.
Okay,
you're doing that to me, dude. I'm so sorry, bro. I am such a
[__] dude. I am such a [__] Oh my god,
dude.
I am bleeding. Oh my god, dude. Oh my god, dude. That did not
just happen, dude. Oh my god, bro. I am bleeding all over the
place, bro. Oh my gosh, dude. I got to go, guys. I don't think
he's worth, guys. No, I'm not. I'm not. I might, Dude. I might
do something stupid, dude. I got to go, guys. I just bought $300,
dude. I got to go. I don't even know where my got to find the
video of him making like 100 grand. I don't even know where my
mouse is. That one's awesome. Oh my god, dude. It's really old
before he blew up recently. Oh my god, dude. No, he's not going
to get his deposit back for doing that to the wall. He lives
with his parents' tree. Oh, damn. He's a grown man who's addicted
to crack cocaine and gambling for those of his parents. What?
Yeah, he's pretty cool. God, dude. Guys,
dude. Oh my
Oh my [__] god, dude.
Oh my god, dude.
Oh my gosh, dude. I cannot believe I just did that to myself,
dude. I cannot believe I just lost $300, dude. Oh my god, dude.
Oh my uh He sounds like uh Midwestern XQC there. Oh my god, dude.
Oh my god, dude. I Jesus Christ. Who is this girl on the bottom
left of the screen over here just what's going on here? Oh, it's
Kelly Jean. Why is she
Uh cuz she's always watching. Dude, it gets worse. Is she Is
she literally watching or is this just like a loop video? Like
what is this? This is just a looped video of her eating popcorn.
Why?
Dude, I'm not going to lie. Just for like a week, I wouldn't
come on your show cuz every time I open I was like, "Oh, the
is here." I was like, "Oh, Kelly's here. I'm not joining, bro."
And then I realized yesterday was a gift. I was like, "Wait a
little bit." Kelly's also awesome. So, you should yourself, Les.
Kelly's a girl who had drama with uh she had drama with with
Tom Bald, right? Yes. Gotcha. Is Tom Bald is he back into the
frame now or is he is he excommunicata? What's the deal with
Tom Bald? Um so what happened? So people think that I caused
this but he's down significantly in viewership like really significantly.
But what actually happened was through all of that he um he accidentally
leaked nudes of a girl he was with from his community and that
exposed to his basically his producer and like a huge part of
his community that he was um that he was seeing this girl romantically
and she told he told the producer he wasn't and the producer
I think had some sort of pseudo romantic relationship with him
and felt betrayed and left like that woman left and when she
left like 40 or 50% of his community left with her but it was
just like he accidentally did this within like a day or two of
our drama happening. So people think that I like ruined this
guy's life, but uh actually he just, you know, he ruined his
own stream a little bit. Okay. But you did hate him, right? Not
really. I hate him. I thought you hated him. I thought I saw
you on Twitter. How was I on him? I don't remember honestly.
Just something negative about him. I might have posted his uh
his clip, but I don't think that means I Yeah, I was going to
say something about the uh what was the clip? Listen, that was
for um that was for a buddy of mine, okay? He messaged me when
I was at work and he's like, "You should tweet this clip right
now at this person." And I was like, "You know what? Say no more.
I'll do that for you." But it's just a clip of him saying that
he'd like to people. No, no,
he was joking. Uh yeah, he was joking. He's clearly joking. It
was a very funny clip. It's actually an awesome clip. We should
get that. Okay, hold on. Do I not have that? Dude, I haven't
used my streamable in a long time and all of my clips are fading.
It's the worst. I used to have so many clips on my stream bowl
and now they're all gone. Someone get me the Tom clip, please.
Uh Tom Tom Bald clip, not the turkey Tom clip. I don't have a
one. How do you know you don't have a clip? Yeah. How do you
know? Well, there's no clip yet. Maybe it's, you know, waiting
in the wings, but to my knowledge, there's no clip. Okay. How
do you know you don't have a clip tree? I mean, it is on my
You say I absolutely based. Thank you. See, I'm not like you.
I'm going to own this. You know what I'm saying? God, dude. She
doesn't have to lie about her, Tom. She's not a
Yeah, I'm a beta for that. For real. Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. I'm
going to I'm going to find Come clean about the Yeah, we need
to find this room clip here. Where is it? Where is it at? It's
got to be right here. I'm more of a silverback gorilla type guy.
I'm not really a guy. No. What is that? There it is. What does
that mean? Is that like a verb? A silverback gorilla somebody.
I'm more into silverbacking.
Just beat the out of them while you're them. That's what it sounds.
It's sort of a sort of it's sort of a junglian philosophy. You
wouldn't understand.
Yian, by the way, I was about to say, was that Carl Jung? That
guy. Carl Jungle. No, the jungle. Like the gorilla is from the
jungle, I assume. Okay. 12 second clip. I think I should rap
somebody. I'm definitely going to rape somebody. What? Yeah,
I'm for sure going to somebody. That's a really good idea.
But you you responded to a clip of someone seriously criticizing
him with this clip. Yes, I did because I so this I was this is
what I was told when I was given when I was like said somebody
messaged me was like you have to do this and I was like okay
this is like a friend of Keeles and they were hoping that Keeles
was going to do a hit piece and include this video in it cuz
Tom had some drama with Keles where he apparently was they they
thought they thought he didn't like consent so she made a video
about him actually and yeah this made it into the video because
of this tweet so mission accomplished I It wasn't. It's not serious
though. It's like clearly a joke. Like Tom is clearly joking
here. He is not a danger to women. Unlike the Tom in this call
who goes gorilla mode. Jesus Christ. What makes you think a woman
would be in danger when I go silverback on her? Wow. Twitch streamers
are just so innovative. Oh my god. I love this woman so much.
She's so built different, bro. Holy mama. She is built different.
Why'd you go Johnny Bravo for a second? Holy mama. Jesus, bro.
Okay.
Man, Jack clip. I was just showing you like this is just the
first Google I found. It's gets way worse. This was like I don't
know a couple hundred in a 19 grand and then he lost it in less
than a minute. Okay, kids got demons. There's a big one. There's
a big boy hit. Make that back, baby. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Oh my
gosh. This isn't happening. Oh my god. Who who goes hard after
hitting the zero after you bet hard on zero?
Why would you do this? He bet on zero and he won and he's going
hard after this. Every odd is the exact same odd. Every Oh, sorry.
You're right. I thought No, no, no. I thought he was betting
green. Sorry. I thought he was betting green. Yeah, he is. He's
pog champ and he made so much money. But like No, no, no. But
you can bet I Sorry. I didn't look at the rest of the board.
I just looked at the zero. But normally I see people bet red
or black or like these ones. I didn't see only betting numbers.
Oh yeah. No.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh my god.
can't stop. The kid can't stop.
He doesn't come back at all. Told you. One minute. That back.
I'm not I'm not That's 16. Oh my god. Yeah, he just lost 19 grand
in a minute. That's going to be Oh, I'm such a Oh,
I am so sad right now.
I deserve this.
Jesus. Gamblers go through all the stages of grief so quickly,
bro. The entire Kubler Ross model in 5 seconds. [__]
Yeah. All of it. From the utmost euphoria to the absolute worst.
Just valleys and mountains instantaneously. It's so awesome.
Jesus Christ.
Just try doing it for a living, bro. It's sweet.
Well, if if someone from kick would return my phone calls, okay,
I got I had a decent amount of viewers. Why can't I get a gambling
contract, Wes? You don't want one. Gambling looks gambling seems
to be depressed for the It is. You want to be You want to kill
yourself? Do you want to be at risk for heart attack? Do you
want to never smile again? It destroys your dopamine centers.
I I I can't remember the last time I enjoyed something like all
my hobbies are no longer my hobbies. Yeah, but here's the thing.
What you're talking about, that's not a hobby. I just want to
hard. Um, the one thing uh about streamers who don't get addicted,
they don't have it like in their jeans, the like any addiction
qualities, they when they promote it, everyone hates it because
it's so disingenuous and fake. Like you're just acting the whole
time, right? The only time people want to watch gambling when
it is degenerate or when you're train wrecks, you're doing million
dollars. But you're going to be doing like normal ass [__]
Maybe you should try to stick to a safe addiction like nicotine
or something that won't. Those are my only addictions.
You smoke just tickle? I do not. I also have a horribly addictive
personality and I would kill myself after like a month of a steak
deal. So that's one thing I like about me. I don't I don't have
I'm not addicted to anything. I can't be addicted. You're addicted
to this white ass hog baby. Jesus kind of wet. God, when she
laughs.
I actually can't take it. I feel like I my breath gets taken
away. Yes, I harass women overloy.
I'm not apologizing. And C, good luck on doing your expose. I
do not care. I'm not going to expose. I'm just saying you have
I'm just I'm just saying you have a Floydian philosophy. What's
that? What do you mean? Well, your breath, right? You can't breathe.
Oh my god.
Banned, dude. Did I I got banned on Twitch once for saying, "Damn
girl, are you a cop? Cuz I can't breathe." I got banned for that
job. You got banned? Really?
Twitch is the worst. It's so
banan, right? They're anti-Foid. They appealed it. Thank God.
But it was so Twitch is run by his doppelgrid
as the CEO. Who's a You should have let that hang for him. He
kept breathing. Tree. Are you a ser?
What's a ser? A ser? There's black people who don't say you just
elk. Why do people call you Jessica when he's clearly just elk?
It's jizz tickle. Yeah, the people just tickles. The
K comes last. Yeah, it does. But you know what? be. So, shouldn't
it be just elk? Uh, yeah, it should. You know what it really
is? Don't tell people. It's not a word cuz it doesn't have any
noun or vowels in it. So, who cares? Yeah, exactly. You just
fill in the vowels. You just assume rather than like pushing
it around like a dyslexic. Oh, dude. Well, Tom, did you see that
weird Keell stream that happened? Which one? That was the latest
one where like she was Yeah, it looks like she's
she is like out of it. Out of it. Is this the one where she responded
to Willie Mack or whatever? Oh, yes. I saw that one clip, but
I haven't seen anything outside of that. I'm uh at this point
I'm kind of uh just, you know, willing to let Keel sunset herself,
so to speak, because uh she's really lost all relevancy like
like
you just did you just advocate for a trans person to hurt themselves,
Tom? Her career. Jesus. Okay. She's going to do that anyway,
whether I whether I advocate or not. But realistically, it's
nice to see like if you think about it, like two years ago, did
you have any hope that this would happen? Like I thought she
was just going to run the internet for the next few years. But
no, she destroyed herself pretty quick. She imploded herself
pretty quick. I'm pretty happy with that. I gave up when Destiny
accepted her apology. I thought it was all over. I thought it
was all over. Luckily, she just couldn't stop. She got accept
apology. That means your career is going to die. The only reason
he's accepting her apology is because she's been dealt karmic
justice already. She's irrelevant. Nobody cares about her. She
can barely And um she's still doing that. I've always wanted
a ratio game. Like she's still doing that ratio. It's like pathetic.
Like she used to be running the internet, you know, getting people
banned on Twitch. Now she's just a nothing. Isn't that epic?
Beat cop
by the way. Yeah. It's kind of cool. Oh. Oh man. I just watched
that Willie Mack video. I think there's going to be more videos.
Are you Did you you did a couple video, right? Yeah, I did recently.
Yeah, I was thinking about doing one on my main channel, but
now that Willy's covering it, I might wait or just not do it
because uh I don't know. I feel like it's probably for the best
that after all this is laid out on the table by people, she just
fades into a relevancy forever and is just remembered as the
person who funded a website for sending hormones to children
without other consent. I feel like that's kind of a just like
what would be ideal cuz I don't want her to like thrive off of
the drama at this point, you know? I would like her to just sink
into the abyss. If Kanye West would asked you to do a documentary
on him, but he has to have uh creative control, would you do
it? No. Yeah, definitely not. But if he wanted to do it and I
and I would have creative control, I would absolutely do it.
Yeah, that's not creative control. I have no integrity, right?
Okay. I I thought it wasn't on moral ground. I thought you more
more or less were just like, "No, I make my own art and nobody
else is going to dictate to me how to do it." No, I mean the
thing is like I'll let the subject of the video have some creative
control. Like if I'm, you know, interviewing and spending time
with them and they're giving their time for me, like if there's
something that they want left out that like is not a huge deal
or there's something private that isn't related to the video
or something like I feel like it's not bad to leave that out
for their own personal safety and privacy. But beyond that, I
mean, I feel like giving the person too much creative control
would be bad because
uh then it's not really their life, you know? I'm trying to see
their real life. At what point has there ever been contention?
Somebody be like, "Hey, maybe don't include that." And you're
like, "I actually think this pretty important to the story or
to the thing." Has that ever happened or not really? Yes. And
uh I'll probably be able to talk about it at some point, but
no worries. It was a pretty crazy one with one of the first ones
I filmed. Uh but uh yeah, it was it wasn't uh there's nothing
out about it. Like nobody knows anything about about this, so
I can't really talk about it, but we'll see if I even have to.
I'm trying to work my way around it. But um more of a thing that
happens is I'll make a video about someone and then they'll contact
me and be like, "Hey,
you went out. You just you just cut out real hard, hey." And
then everything went quiet. Okay. Okay. So, typically, uh no,
that's not a problem. But I've only filmed a few of these IRL
docs. On one of them that I filmed, I did have a problem like
that. Um which maybe I'll be able to talk about eventually, but
uh nobody nobody knows any details now. I might be able to work
around it. Typically what's happened in the past when I haven't
been filming with them and I've just been doing like the normal
video essay stuff is someone after the fact will email me and
be like can you take that out and I usually just ignore it because
it's like
unless it's like a privacy risk to them and they are someone
who doesn't deserve to have a privacy risk you know then I won't
take it out. Damn the judge and executioner if they should be
stalked and well if they're evil I mean who cares right I'm not
encouraging it but if uh if someone who has with dogs you know
gets docks I mean is that really my problem? I guess we're not
doing an interview. I guess we're not. You're also not famous
enough anyway, so you don't have to worry about it. Why don't
you do one on the Liver King then? Why don't you get me Miskf
and then we'll talk, Wes. You can come after you. Mis, get me.
Wow, he's summoning you, Wes. All right. How much am I paying
you, bro? Bring me
What are you giving to me? Well, the problem with the Miskip
one is I would have to talk about Adriana Lee and he doesn't
want to talk about that. The problem is there's a lot of [__]
that he would not talk about, so I never do it. Uh, would he
talk about what punch he landed on Mitch's face to knock him
to the ground? Or the Mitch thing was based, though. Yeah, the
Mitch thing. The Mitch thing was like epic. 100%. The guy deserves
a rat. I mean, even if he didn't deserve it is just like it was
epic. It's epic to punch someone, you know? It's based even if
he's innocent. No, but I feel like I need to
personality.
Mitch made the critical mistake of with Msk when he was in the
middle of a cycle. Okay. Yeah. I want to ask about that
one.
You think he's on You think he's on steroids? I feel like he
doesn't look big enough for that. 100 No, his veins is a dead
giveaway at some point. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. His veins are 100%
dead giveaway. He has
look
and see what comes up. Pretty sure he wore a tank top at some
point and had like the most horrendous backne
I think that's like a big big Is it Is it this? Let me send you
the picture. I think it's this picture is the one people are
saying. Uh,
his shoulders do look kind of crazy in this, but it could be
naturally achieved maybe just with a lot of time. Thing it hasn't
been timed. It's not totally impossible. He disappeared after
like the Adriana Lee thing and then was like jacked the next
like like two months with Tren. Yeah, he definitely I bet you
I know who got him on it, too. I What do you think? What do you
think he's on? He might just be on test. I mean, he's not on
trend. Even if he is on steroids, I don't really care. Like,
who cares? He might I feel like with Tren you could kind of tell
from the personality a lot of the time. Yeah. He would have aspirations
if he was on trend, wouldn't he? You would think that, but I've
met someone who who I know was on trend and they didn't seem
that nuts. Really? I'm actually not sure that these physiques
are terribly different. It just looks like he shaved his chest
in one of them and not in the other. There looks like better
lighting.
He's a little bit more heavy. Just a tiny bit heavier in the
one on the right. You got to understand the one on the left is
months of him working out, right? That's not just like before
he started his whole workout art again. Looks pretty big already,
though. It's like two months later and he looks dope. I feel
like
way that picture on the right, I don't even think that's that
recent. I think it's like 6 months old. No, that that's like
right after that's like when he was still not streaming from
the Adriana Lee drama. I remember when these pictures dropped
like he wasn't even that bellies in his delts. So that they're
more rounder and fuller. Oh yeah, he's a little bit bigger in
the right one. I feel like it's He is bigger, but couldn't that
just be from lifting and lighting and everything? Like he doesn't
look that insane. The only thing the only thing is like the traps
look a little crazy, but I don't think Oh, yeah. There you go.
Yeah, that dude. I don't think you can necessarily conclude that
he's on Roy from that. It's not like an insane like Sam Sulike
type meme, you know? Depends on how long it took took him to
get this big. I mean, this size. Sorry. Exactly. The time is
the important thing here. Well, how long was it? I think uh I
don't know how to say numbers. Someone's saying the size of his
head is a dead giveaway. I don't even know what that means.
Uh he just sort of has like the actor build of like a large head.
Yeah, bobblehead type meme. He's bobbling. He is bobbling. Back
to the Minecraft here. Boom. Back to the Minecraft. Hell yeah,
dude. Kick doesn't know anything about Kicks putting me in the
Minecraft category. I have to move myself out all the time. Really?
I need a way. I need a way to tell them, hey, don't move me.
Don't move my categories. We are just chatting. Oh, wait. This
guy uh this guy Canude made a video about him on steroids. Isn't
Canude his business partner? Doesn't he have incentive to Yeah,
they own a gym together. I like you would have incentive to lie
then. I don't know if we can trust him necessarily. Of course
he does. Bias. Pretty sure. Yeah, I'm pretty sure Canute watched
like that Mitch video and was just like I think Canoot's the
got him on Roids, bro. Yeah, it's either Canute or Wake. I don't
think Wake's ever done Roids. You're just exposing him right
now. You're exposing him. That's That's kind of obvious. It's
my opinion. I don't have anything to back it. You're getting
kicked out of the gym. You're not going to be able to lift anymore.
I'm not going to kick me out of the gym. They're going to call
you gay and fat and say you can't come anymore. Do you guys all
know who Wick TV is? No. Yes. Yes. Yes. Did you guys see the
Keemstar tweet? Hate when I'm guy who's always left out. Hold
on. Let me pull up the Wick Wick runs politics panels like Twitch
panels but in a Destinyless Twitch poll. So,
uh, Keemstar is getting on him for being racist. Twitch streamer
being racist AF.
Some Beyonce tweet and he says Twitter absolutely
watermelon Twitter that is
base
wick. You're enjoying. How could that not be racist? Kind of
takes the sales out of your moral indignation when Tree laughs
so hard, doesn't it? Are you saying the black Twitter? He's just
saying black people love watermelons. I thought watermelon was
a thing. He used the word black. He used water. It's Beyonce
of like the number one black female artist. No, no, no. Beyonce
who bleeds like a white woman and has a blonde wig. She is culturally
appropriating white women. So, uh, yeah. But what else could
he mean besides black people when he
What do you think he mean?
Down here in the south. What are you talking about? I love watermelon.
He
my black friends and I I ask him what he wants to eat and I'll
be like, "Oh, do you want fried chicken and watermelon?" Like
that's I don't know. I just can't understand what else would
be. Watermelon and fried chicken and all that stuff is not an
insult down here in the south. It's a complete coincidence. I
don't think it's an insult as much as it is just like a a haha
black thing. Haha black. I don't know how to describe it. Dog
whistles. You're literally black right now. I mean, if they if
they if they ever want to be racist, just say do what I say and
basketball Americans. You know that. That's a funny one. Watermelon
is just Yeah. Well, no, no, no. Hold on. Watermelon is supposed
to be Palestine, just so we're all clear. Yeah. Oh. Oh, watermelon
is Palestine. I didn't know that. Wait, how is that Palestine?
Cuz the flags are the same color. Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
that's not racist.
Well, I thought he was just saying, "Haha, black people eat watermelons.
Haha, your Twitter's because you're black and you eat watermelon."
By the way, black people eat watermelon. Haha. People eat the
most watermelon down here. Uh, black people eat the most watermelon
in the South. You're crazy. I don't know how many cookouts you've
been to. I can't stand on that hill. I've been to a lot and they
never skimped on the watermelon and they usually have that cut
up into shapes and stuff. I never been to a white barbecue. I
have a watermelon in our kitchen. So yeah, I ain't never been
to a white barbecue that had watermelon and that's probably the
worst thing about white barbecue to be honest. Instead you get
by your uncle
salad with raisins in it. It's the worst thing.
Oh, I thought you say that's good. Okay. I was like
the worst. You said the worst thing about white barbecues. No,
they put raisins in their potato. sourcing off black barbecues.
All the guns. Jesus Christ. The fact that it's in lowincome housing.
No, it's not a broken down car. Is it a driveway? The fact that
there's no dad's there to grill the meat. What is happening right
now? What is What is going on with the two of you? Insanity.
Jesus Christ.
All right, I got to go eat some watermelon. I'll see you guys
later. Oh, that's funny. See you later, Tom. Re tower. Oh, that's
funny. Oh Jesus. I love Tree so much, man. The optics there were
too much for Tom. Okay, dude. Queen is my or Tree is my Beyonce
and I'm a watermelon American and I love it.
All right. Um, oh boy. Okay. Does Wes know who Lauren de Laguna
is? Is Wes aware the white chick who does the politics that is
like a little autistic that I was on the show with? Or is she
the hot blonde one that's a super Republican? She ain't the hot
blonde one. Wait, who's the hot blonde one? I don't know. Lauren
Southern. Is that who I'm thinking of? Oh, yeah. That's who you're
thinking of. De Laguna is like the white chick, super pale, dark
hair, right?
Kind of. Let me use find her here. Social media clatter or whatever
really changes because I remember her on a podcast if it's the
same girl. She was like, I have a husband. Where was this party?
I think it was here at the end. You probably
pretty intelligent. This is her here. Oh, that's not who I'm
thinking of. I don't know who that a picture of her in the chair
or something here. Who the is that for this interview?
Uh kind of. She um she's like threatening to sue him now or trying
to get him in trouble with the law. Okay. Okay. Yeah. So she's
like losing her. So this I mean they seem to be pretty close
here. What I found from spending a week with the guy was a pretty
intelligent I I think she's just Yeah. A little upset that she's
not Molina 2.0.
So, she's going to I don't know if she's going to snitch.
Well, I'm What's appealing about being Destiny's bottom? I don't
know. I'm trying to get people to like I don't get it. Like,
you just sit in the other room and you have to hear him angrily
snarl about 12 hours a day and every time you walk through the
kitchen, he's playing some factory simulator game. I I wish I
wish I wish he was, but he's not. I wish. I don't want to sit
in a house that's like it sound I feel like I'm walking on eggshells
all the time.
Destiny is the type of dude where if like a girl farted around
him be like gross don't do that. Like I I could be comfortable
in that house. Bro, I don't understand why women would want to
be there. I get it. Like he like debates them into him. But after
that like once once they this finish they got to kind of like
light like realize what you can't debate someone into you. be
the one of anyone could. No, Destiny is absolutely the number
one manipulator on the planet and it takes no physical attraction
on the planet. There's no one like Destiny on this planet that
is such a goofball that more women and it has nothing to do with
physical attraction. It's 100% mental. You know, the humor you
you understand that being funny gets you a long way. I know it
does. I've my entire life despite being morbid obese and my comedy
carries but it's not comedy for him and I that's such it's the
confidence it's the confidence it is it's the air of confidence
the fact that he's knows he's the smartest in the room he'll
argue with anyone with thing and be the be right about everything
and know everything etc etc and women are like wow I guess I
better him this guy knows everything he's pretty or something
nobody actually fights physically anymore they all fight with
words okay when it comes to fighting with words this guy is like
Bruce Lee What happened with the good error? Why don't people
just beat the [__] out of each other? People just
run their mouths now and they never get any justice brought their
way. So a kid when people disagreed and you would just hit the
other person and then and then and then you win. Yeah. And then
you win. Now if you hit someone suddenly there's a Twitter post
and a YouTube expose and your cats have been stolen and your
kids have been stolen and your house is holding repos. Maybe
maybe it's a third world experience, but when you beat another
kid up, how does their older brother, their uncle, or even their
family doesn't show up at your door and start [__]
with you, too? They
doesn't happen in the stage. Yeah. If you if it's a little child,
if if two children are fighting, of course, it doesn't happen.
But if a older person beats up a little child, a kid, yes. They'll
come and beat the Yeah. But people understand kids will be kids.
Kids fight. Yeah. Yeah. So, it's normal. They're like, "Oh, did
you They make up really quickly. When two kids fight, they Yeah,
they make up. That is the number one way to become a come bonding,
lasting friends with someone is getting a phys physical altercation
with." Yeah. There's something in your testosterone or you're
in your pherommones that just like instantly you're like, "That's
my guy." Like I don't know how to explain it, but should have
happened more, bro. People should just fight. [__]
Twitter, dude. Twitter fan. Are you Are you on Twitter tree?
Yes. Oh, man. Uh I'll be right back here. I'm not really active.
I'm not really Okay. Okay, I miss Twitter so much. I'm not active
on what? What happened? I'm a So, they permanently banned me.
Will you stop with this nonsense? That's literally what they
think. That's literally what Twitter thinks.
But what happened though? I was this 22-y old girl in Thailand
who was like petite. Uh, and she was a Zoomer and she was making
a Tik Tok. And I made a video of her making a Tik Tok and then
panning my face being uncomfortable. And the the the caption
was, "Uh, man, the worst thing about children is having to watch
them make Tik Toks." Why would you say
So do that. Hilarious. Oh god, it was so funny. And I thought
everything went on Twitter. Like I truly thought there's no way
you'd get banned for saying you're a pedophile.
But they banned me and they instant deny every appeal. Like they
won't even review it. Nothing. And it sucks because Twitter is
the only social media I ever use that I ever like. I don't use
Instagram. I don't use MySpace, Facebook, any of that gay. I
love Twitter though. And I'm exile. Wait, is Zirka banned off
Twitter? Cuz I'm pretty sure he's also made some That guy actually
kids. There's a big difference. Yeah, he's not banned off of
Twitter. But that's why don't give up, Wes. Just keep give it
some time and then apply for re uh appeal again. It's it's they
they have my account set where it's not a human review. It's
instant robotic denial. Oh, damn. Yes. Like I need to literally
like go to Twitter HQ and be like I'm gonna blow this up if someone
doesn't help me type [__]
I gota go terrorist mode if I'm shockingly if you actually made
that post on the Twitter platform you would be banned less than
you are now.
Yeah. Apparently terrorism's that's okay. Well, he's joking but
Oh, a person. Oh, that's definitely a child. He's so cringe.
It's not like I even I post a video of us or anything like that.
I would get in all fairness. I wonder who at Twitter is going
to open up the vlog and be like, "Hi, this is best by the way.
Just let you know that person who looks very petite is actually
not underage. She just looks very young. So, could you like get
me a man or something like that?" It seems as simple as no one
would ever actually tweet that. That's a No one would film the
person that child
somebody would have been like really careful with the jokes.
I don't know, dude. I I I have no limit to my joke. Like I'll
say all the most [__] up despite not being a not
being a racist, not being a bigot of any type. I'll say the most
[__] up [__] cuz I think it's funny.
Uh so but apparently that one's too far. I don't know. I get
it. Protect kids. I mean I I respect the decision, but can look
at least like stop giving me robotic denials. Like I understand
the ban. I get it. But let me just let me explain. Goddamn. I'll
show you I'll show you the How long ago was this? I don't know.
Been a while since I was in Thailand. So like four months, 5
months. You stayed in Thailand for how long? 2 months. Okay.
I'm going back in five, six. Is it true that you know you can
bribe to get a lot of things that you want? Like bribing is really
big there. Like bribe the police. You can bribe That's what my
friend says. You can also bribe the police. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
What do you mean bribe other than police? No, you can bribe everybody.
You can bribe anything. Every buy anything. But yeah, you can
bribe police too, other than like super up, but like drugs or
anything uh like if they were to tow your car, anything like
that. Yeah, they're every everything is corrupt in Thailand,
which makes it the devil's playground. It's so fun. I even found
out today that there's casinos, like backdoor hidden casinos.
I've been looking for them for so long because they're banned.
Like casinos aren't legal there. Oh, casinos are not legal there.
Not in Thailand. You got to go
uh Cambodia is the closest one. Philippines or Macau or Singapore.
I would love to visit there one time and probably go to the Buddhist
temples and yeah, the temples are gorgeous, but they they get
to like the first couple blow your off, but then you realize
they all are the same. It's one of those things that uh gets
old. You do it like one day and you're like, "Okay, I've seen
every temple in the whole country." But they are insanely magnificent.
I spent a lot of time there to meditate and to also have a conversation
with a couple of monks. that are not on the I've never seen a
real ass monk there. I don't know if they have like monk monasteries
in Thailand. They probably do, but I don't know. I went to quite
a few different cities. I never Yeah, I never saw like an orange
robe monk. I feel like that's other parts of um That's Tibet,
right? I mean, it's it's in a couple places, but it would be
in Tibet a lot more than Yeah, their temples are to uh they're
like they're Buddhist temples, but they're I've never seen Buddhist
monks. It's weird. Yeah, I think uh not every Buddhist temple
has like monks there. Like the same kind of Okay. Like Dolly
Lama type monks, but the tie is like they have them in Thailand,
too, apparently. But yeah, I feel like they do. I just never
saw them. Different color robes, you know? Maybe they kind of
get sick of the orange every once in a while. You were looking
for an orange. I wonder why they all wear orange. They probably
switch it up. Why the are all monks always wearing orange or
tan? Those are the only two monk robes I've ever seen. I think
orange is the belly chakra, I think. All right.
Interesting. Well, I got to I'm hitting up the gym so I can lose
that belly chakra. So, no orange for me. I'm good without it.
We are different colors. Where's your parrot? Asleep. So, on
that cage behind me. Oh, rest nice and easy. Yeah, it's like
2:00 a.m. So, poor little guy's got to get some rest. Oh, okay.
Yeah, you two are Canadians. Wait, wait, me and Wolf Gang or
you ain't Wolf Gang?
I mean, yeah, but she said that with a smile on their face, too.
She's like, "You guys are Canadians." I was like, "The hell?"
Cuz you're not Americans. You're goofy to us. You're silly snow
Mexicans. Let's be honest, dude. Jesus. Oh, that's actually closer
to home than you'd think with me. Logistical. I'm not sure. I'm
not very white either, so I'll just have to take that one on
the chin. Kind of like Wes's child. Tree. What do you what? Kind
of like your Twitter child. She took my [__] on her
chin. Um, yeah. Or something along those lines. Yeah. Oh, good
one. Good one. Good one. Good one. Good one. Thank you. Um, I
thought so. What do you think just Tickle's racial ethnic like
ethnic makeup is if you were to guess? If he's in Canada,
probably indigenous and and Indian or something. When I say
the way he talks about Indians, I don't think so. Daughter feather,
bro. Uh, dots.
Really? You have Indian You have Indian blood in you? Yeah. How
much? Um,
Oh, wow. A lot. How much How How uh black are you? Uh, not at
all cuz I sit inside all day. No. How much African is your blood?
Oh, like again 0% cuz I sit inside all day. But no, you can actually
for that reason. It's just 0%.
No. You know what? I'm not going to expose you.
What? Nothing.
Sorry. You know what? Hold on, Wes. I have a different answer.
50% and it's all from the waist down. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you for setting that up. You got it on the third try. There
you go, JS. Yeah, there you go. I just think white people should
be able to say it. Okay, that's just a principal position I have.
I don't have a problem with you all saying. Oh, she said it.
Let's go.
What? Oh, dude. Oh, that's awesome. I don't know. You can say
it, too. I give you guys passes. Dude, do you know still to this
day, people think I'm actually a racist because I used to have
this bit on Destiny's show all the time on the Rod show with
Destiny that I would always say white people should be able to
say the answer and now everyone thinks that I think that it has
I so I won't say that has never. No. Yeah.
You should. We if it it I'm not going to say a word. Not the
hard not the hard R. I know. I know. But if it's someone else's
identity and they feel like I'm trying to like [__]
with their identity or steal it or I'm like I'm culturally appropriating
it, I don't mind not saying it. I don't have this burning. It's
the same thing with trans people. If you want I don't give a
I don't really think you're a woman, but if you want to be called
a woman, I will call you a woman because I don't want to deny
your humanity or like like make you feel like [__]
So it's the same reason I don't say the Okay. I feel like it
it just is problematic. The doesn't deny our our existence though.
Yeah. Well, it kind of cheapens it when a white person says it.
I mean, if it doesn't cheapen your existence for me to call you
the cword like a saltine. Yeah, but you never my people never
enslaved or your people never enslaved me, bro. Your people were
enslaved by the But your people never enslaved me and my people
enslaved you or your people. So, I got there's a [__]
guess what I'm glad that can't happen cuz I'm not somewhere in
Africa with a goddamn bone in my titties hanging down. I'm just
saying like I'm glad I feel rude. I feel like I'm off like your
like generations of black people. Like if ghosts were real, they'd
be like trying to stab me over this [__] I think
they have problem with a lot of other things before they come
after you for what you're saying. I think you'd be at the bottom
of their list of priorities if it were to like haunt or come
back.
I used to say I grew up saying it because I grew up in a black
community and like a lot of my friends are black and I was like
they said it to me and they're like, "No, it's cool. You can
say And back then I was like, "Of course." Yeah. But nowadays,
white people that grew up with us, I mean, it was no big deal
in school. It's also the impact that your words have. I don't
want to propagate it and let well like have other people think
that I think it's okay that they can say it and then a bunch
of white people in my chat are saying the word. I don't know.
It just makes me uncomfortable. But in private, I say it like
with my friends and I call all my like friends the There's no
hesitation like at all. There's no way I'm more outraged than
No, it's 100% built into me. It was for 10 years. The hardest
thing about streaming for me like the taking my vocab out wasn't
the epsler. It was calling people the or just saying it in like
all like every third sentence. Not racially, but like you know
it's just built into your vocab when you use it for so long.
Whenever someone who's black is like, "Oh, I give you the pass."
And like I just stutter. I can't I cuz then it sounds
dude. It's different once you use it for so long and it just
becomes part of your vocab that you replace so many words with.
It's a great filler word. It's such a good filler. It's so good
for everything. It just feels good to say. It does. It really
does. It feels clean. It feels you feel
I don't know. You feel good. Calling you a chicken. What's this?
What's this on on a Yeah, you I'm a chicken.
This is the video we watched before. Tree
on the presentation. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah.
I uh I didn't have much
to be honest. We're like we'll like little We're like the little
meme where the little child has the bold please, sir. I want
some more. You know, want some more drama? May I have some more?
I mean, there will be Destiny in this like bot. Well, you watch
it with me tree, but he kind of copes and is like, "Oh, this
is just boring. It'll go away." It's like, I don't think this
is No, it won't. I'm pretty sure. Once Lauren sees this
reply from him that she's going to like spur on her Twitter and
her do a stream and this that and the other and so yeah, I wonder
if Zena is going to be safe
cuz she's friends with Lauren and that coming out like that was
kind of you know what I mean? I don't think I don't think Zena
literally told her
Zena literally said, "Hey, I'm I'm live or like I'm on this stream
right now. If you don't want if you don't want anything here,
then you shouldn't talk." And then Lauren just got it. Yes. Oh,
what? Oh, okay. What? Yeah. No, Lauren. Absolutely. Zena was
like very clear like, "I'm on a stream right now. If you want
me to mute, you have to tell me to." And Lauren was like, "No,
I'm not going to talk about anything." And then she just like
Yeah. cooked up a yaparoni and cheese as your boy relevant would
say. Oh, why would you tell me that? Now I'm hungry. Oh, yapperoni
and cheese. Whipped up a yappuccino.
That's pretty good, too. I like that. That's a new one. Any more
fest drama happened recently?
No. Um,
actually it did, but I I can't even really go into it. Why not?
Wait, what? Why not? Why not? Why not? Okay, talk about it a
little bit, but um the Paragon guy like basically he posted some
stuff in my Discord that it seemed like he was trying to show
his job interview. He he tried to show a job offer like with
how much money he would make and their like offer was incredibly
suspicious. There's a bunch of people who work in tech in my
Discord, including me, and we're like, "Yeah, this job offer
for like a number of reasons seems clearly fake." And then people
found the template for the job offer that he like used and we're
just like, "Yeah, this is really suspect." And so he got quite
agitated about that and he sent me a ton of pictures like from
his office. And then he said that everything that's been happening
is based on like stuff that was happening in a group chat he's
in. And then he sent me something like three dozen selfies
that were like showing that he had sent these selfies to a group
chat. And I honestly you it sounds like I'm just having like
my own breakdown, but I'm not. This happened in my DMs. I just
I don't want to like I don't want to What the [__]
does have to do with pasting? Oh, this was the from my community.
Yeah, this is the This is the guy who randomly went full hog.
Yeah. Yeah, this is the guy who went full hog. Yeah, Harrison
should be making royalties off of that, dude. Cuz that that took
off. I cannot believe that. I think for a while she was going
to try and sell like a little plushy of a hog or something like
that. I hope that went well for
Arizonan. What about wait like I'm going to keep beating my Wait,
do you not know that? Hold on a second. Uh there was a meme for
a while that took off with like a I think what happened. I think
Eric got banned for reading a comment or something like that.
Take this with a grain of salt because I don't remember exactly
how it went down. There was somebody on her Twitch chat that
said like oh you can ban me but that won't stop me from beating
my hog or like you can't stop me from beating my hog or something
like that. That was from years ago. Yeah, that was that was Wes
on an alt. Who's
someone took it to her and she for it? Yeah, he has
um and also a former like moderator of DGG. I just want to pull
up Pixie's messages from earlier tonight. Just
a lot. True noise. Exclusive drama streamers are the bottom of
the food chain bacteria that literally feeds on everyone's waist.
Pixie, pick literally any political topic and debate me on it.
You are a [__] I will pick anything. I may be a drama
streamer, but you are an actual. So, let's go. Uh, sounds like
an adome, bro. Uh, it is an at home. This person just talks to
me. This is um this is Lauren De Lagona. Yeah, but I'm not an
exclusive drama streamer. Okay. This is Lauren De Laguna's roommate.
Yeah. Like really just tickle uh content of you made you and
you. What do you mean? What do you mean by unique? Do you understand
that every one of these panels is unique, right? Do you not understand
that? The DG chat. I haven't visit the chat in a while. I miss
DG, bro. What are the boys doing? Also, just so you know, Wes,
I literally like review debates and stuff on my own, too. Yeah.
With I'm terrible takes, I'm sure. Paring other people's opinions
that have already been said 20 times. Nope. Nope. Not at all.
Do you consider yourself a political commentator?
No. I mean, no, cuz I haven't made money commenting on politics.
I didn't say professional. I'm just saying, would you consider
yourself a political commentator? Uh, in comparison to most people
in this community or most people who are adjacent to Destiny
and make political claims. Yeah, for sure. Cherry and Pixie don't
like each other. I don't know if Cherry and Pixie don't like
each other. I Pixie just talks to me all the time. What? Pixie
says, "Can someone link the VOD where Cherry is talking about
me with JS?" Oh, where did she say this? Is this on the logs
that I have on the screen? Yeah. Uhhuh. I'm looking at it. Oh,
apparently that was in February. I have no idea. I just had these
up to like look at this one. Oh, okay. Okay. Yeah, this is just
tonight. So, that's old news. Okay. Yeah, I thought they was
I thought those two were cool with each other. Okay. I did do
this. And you know why I did this?
Nse. Who's NSE? Not so Aerodite. Not soite. Oh, and that's aite.
I did do this. Literally one for donations. Oh, you guys don't
have this up. Sure. My bad. My bad, guys. But I did do this.
You know why? Because Pixie, that's why. Pixie, you and I still
cool. You should just own your own what? Oh, I'm also a drama
streamer. I'm just saying that Pixie is saying, "Oh, you're an
exclusive drama streamer, so you're like News Network." Sure,
I'm fine with that. I'm absolutely fine with that. Okay. I just
don't like her pretending that she does anything useful in the
world. Oh, did she say she did? Yeah. Well, the implication when
she's judging me is that she does. Oh, I guess she goes on panels
and and makes an ass of herself. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Does she?
Yeah, regularly. Or maybe she likes you and this is her way of
she's negging you. Sorry, Tree. She's negging the out of you.
It's a love language.
Yeah, maybe. Maybe she's Oh my god. I just I just heard Just
holding back every insult on the book, dude. The moment you guys
said that, he's like, "Oh, maybe." Yeah, I
there was a joke I had, but I just can't do it. Okay, dude. I
heard the inside of your head, dude. You're You're thought about
something I would say, huh? Wouldn't say it. Oh, for sure. Now
he's dwelling on it. I just
I can't I can't. It just I can't say it. It's such a funny Okay,
I'll say it. J Tickle wanted to call me a neggger. He said all
because all I do is neg, but he's too scared to say the word
neger. What's going on, guys? It's getting a bit warm, isn't
it?
So, it's so fun, dude. It's getting a bit hot in here.
Temperature going up. It's like spring. The first day of spring.
I thought you were going to commentate on the fact that Pixie
looks like a zombie or some [__] No, I would. I literally
don't faith ducks. I'm not going to talk about Pixie's looks,
and I get mad at anyone who does. So, okay. Well, face cam. I
really want to know what you look like. Uh, I could send you
a picture. Okay. I promise I won't leak it. I don't know if I
feel like I can trust you. Okay.
I've never done I've never leaked a single thing of anyone. I
am. You don't know this, but I'm kind of like the He just leaks
pictures of of his own that I know, bro. I got feelings. Okay.
Name name someone, bro. I'll tell you if I got dirt on him. Name
anyone. Northern Lion. Oh, I love Northern Lion. No, I love that
guy, too. I've never spoken to him. He's my new uh I've recently
become a like fanatical of him. Oh my god. I watch the out of
him, bro. I've watched every sing that Library of Lo YouTube.
I've watched every single video on it that isn't like eight hours
long. But yeah, I love that guy. I have none. Hold on. Where'd
you say this channel was? Library of Lo. It's way better than
his YouTube. This guy is like his number one moderator and he
makes videos for him. I'll I'll link it to you. It's It's YouTube.
happening with um there you go. I linked it. I just got a notification
for that bath. What is wrong with you? Why would you Why would
you get that tweet up that fast? That's absurd. What were you
saying? Tree, can I be honest with you? Yes. I hope more than
anything in the world that you get divorced because I'm in the
wings, bro. Every night before I go to bed, I pray that like
your husband cheats on you and you you leave his husband. Well,
we're not getting divorced if we cheat. If he cheats because
or I it doesn't we we discussed this already when we were um
if he cheats then that means I get to cheat. So Oh, I hope he
cheats. So Holy
Wes just got all the motivation he needs for the next eight weeks
at the gym. Okay. And the next I just got I just got the motivation
to spend $1,000 literally just dooring hookers to your house.
Wes will be there and one time he'll him and I'm going to pay
him to record it. Wes's gonna pull a Bugs Bunny where he goes
over the bar with like a wig. Yeah, dude. I He could me if it
means I get the tree, dude. I'll take that. Tit for tat. You
know, you got to be dedicated to your craft. Oh, that's just
evil. That's No, I'm just kidding. Anyway, don't worry. Oh, is
he though?
But if Tree was like a a fimdom, she might be the one woman on
the planet I would let like put me in like a [__]
mask and beat the [__] out of me. Did you you haven't
been beaten before, so I wouldn't do it. It has to be something
like I've never met a woman strong enough, though. I think I
have a submissive side, but I always have to be hyper dominant
because every woman it just happens. There's such We talked about
that today. We talked about how cuz she's dominant, too. And
and he was talking about how men how men tend to say up things
just so we can buck up at them. You know what I'm saying? Dominate
them. So that's Yes, we 100% do. Yeah, you're right. You're 100%
right. It's called poking the bear. And if you poke the bear
hard enough, it'll come on you. What? Who said that? Bear come
on me
Weird. Strange. Jesus.
This is true. He's correct. Are you going to cover the Dark Viper
situation? I am. But hold on. We'll just we'll finish up with
this stuff, guys. Sorry, I was reading a chat message tree. You
go ahead. No, I was gonna say, are you ready to shut down?
Uh, pretty quick. I'm just I want to laugh at this Chud situation.
Chud so funny. Oh, okay. Sure. Chud tweeted out this guy Dark
Viper AU is like a schizophrenic, like a completely unmedicated,
paranoid schizophrenic YouTuber. And he DMCA some video Chud
did on him.
And this guy like is abusing the DMCA uh situation on YouTube.
And basically Chud, you know, countered it and said like, "I'm
ready to go to court." And this guy's apparently been talking
to YouTube a whole bunch about this whole situation. And it's
just really funny because as a part of their correspondence with
YouTube, they literally said like, "Hey YouTube, could you keep
all of these emails like private because we think Chudlo Logic
will use them to make fun of us. So please don't let him see
them." And Google was like, "Uh, I didn't read that." And sent
I think all the correspondents to Chud or someone did somehow
he got it. So any I'll read the tweet real quick. Remember when
Dark Viper AU filed a DMCA against me last year for reacting
to one of his videos and it got knocked back by YouTube? Well,
he hired a lawyer to file it on his behalf, who also messed up
the DMCA and had to go backwards and forwards with YouTube for
months to finally get get it through. As part of their correspondence,
his lawyer, probably at Dark Viper's request, demanded YouTube
keep the emails private because they were worried I would make
content out of them and defame him. They alluded to taking legal
action against both me and YouTube if they passed it on to me.
Well, the good news is I have the full email chain and we'll
be going over it tomorrow on stream. Let me see what it says
in the email chain here. We also stipulate that this correspondence
not be shared in part or in full with Chudlogic and must be kept
confidential. We believe it is highly likely that Chud Logic
will use copies of any correspondence to create further content
on his channel that may either be a defamatory in nature or b
will lead to further infringement of our client's work. Each
outcome would be at the detriment of our client and reference
to our client being a copyright abuser which may give rise to
an action in uh an action in defamation. On this point, we refer
to your to the following videos for your reference only, which
is the Chudlo Logic video they struck or no, it was his follow-up
video
cuz he's gone through all of his correspondence with them too.
Should YouTube breach the confidential nature? Hold on, I need
to zoom out on this. That's not legally binding. What? Who the
lawyer did they hire? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, they just threatened
basically if you breach the confidential nature of this correspondence,
we'll have to take appropriate legal action against both YouTube
and Chud Logic. Yeah. No, that's just a threat they're hoping
will uh will keep this guy at bay. But this dude will make content
out of anything. Okay. So, he's just based like that. Said we'll
do that. Yeah. It's going to be it's going to be great. I'm sad
that I'm probably going to fall asleep and miss most of it, but
I'm going to be hilarious. Uh, it's going to be awesome. I think
I'm probably tune in for that. I don't watch Chad uh um content.
I But I did watch the the Vosch is Vosch stream funny as And
then I'll probably watch this one too. Does Vosch fall off after
I got exposed? He was a
He's No, he's still doing live streams. So he didn't like I think
his his viewers are down, I'm pretty sure. Yeah. Is he taking
and people still don't care. Like, [__] me, bro.
Wait, dog. I don't think Sorry. Horse, I think you mean. Oh,
is it horse? My bad. Yeah, it's a horse. I hate that lolli. That
lolly is not dumb.
I don't know if he's falling off or not. How do we
month referring to Lo not kosher is very funny to me. So, his
average fell, but his peak went up. Oh, the average low. Yeah.
So, February it was um 5,400 and then 4,600 for March so far.
But I don't have like data that goes back super far.
Solid subscribers. I need subs though. I hate his guts. But I'm
going to tell you what. Oh wow. Look at that. Here's the thing.
While he still will get decent amount of views, but not he his
his fantasy as surpassing
Destiny is now down the toilet. So that's good cuz I remember
he was arrogantly like saying that he was going to pass Destiny
and views and numbers and everything like that and popularity.
I think I think technically at some point like three or four
years ago he did actually surpass Destiny and subscribers on
YouTube only. I think he did but then he got and then he did
the fortress thing and it's just been a comedy of errors for
Vos since then. What's the fortress thing? Said he wasn't going
to interact or talk with Wait, you could probably explain it
better. Sure, Wolf Gang was going to get it, but it's um it's
basically he he was going to stop doing a bunch of collaborations
because he got he felt like everybody was just making fun of
him and leeching off of him or trying to like directly harm him.
So, he was like, "We're just going to do our content in our own
little space here." And Destiny did the opposite and started
reaching out to everybody for collaborations and exploded. Yeah,
totally the opposite. Yeah. Let me ask you a question very quick.
is, and I don't want to get into the nitty-gritty of this, but
just quickly, is Hassan like dropping in viewership or something?
Why is he suddenly covering Destiny now? Dropping in viewership?
I don't I don't know. I don't keep up with him. Like, I have
no idea. But it's just weird that now he's doing like a full
turnaround today on stream. I don't know if it was a joke or
not, but I heard someone saying that he Hassan was reviewing
old Destiny versus New Destiny or some [__] like
that. Well, he covered up Destiny though with his own image,
so for the Picklestein stuff. Yeah, he did. And past 365 days
don't look good for Hassan. So good. He'll he'll turn it around
though. Like he's still hovering around 20k. Like obviously I
would murder like a hundred infant children to get his money.
I mean metaphorically, but he will turn it. It won't happen until
like this summer cuz then that's when the election political
season is going to come around and yeah think it'll be hard for
him to fall off too hard during that, right? Yeah.
That's what's saving him right now. That's what's going to save
him. He's the last major political guy on Twitch. Um the biggest
one. Yeah, he's the biggest one. Yeah, there's some when Steven
got banned. Um he Hassan is now like like I think doesn't denims
get like 5K views like 5K average or something? Denims gets like
a stupid amount of viewers. Oh no, only a thousand. Okay. No,
she only averages like a thousand viewers or something. I don't
know who this is.
Uh she's like a Hassan tier lefty streamer. Oh, about Mike from
PA. Uh what else? I know who that is. God, that Raj Royale is
still one of the best. Yeah. Okay, this guy's not doing quite
as well. I mean, he's doing well if you go back three years though.
Four years. Dang. This guy is like my nuts. Yeah. Well, you know
what, Tree? I'm going to do that with Destiny and I'm going to
make Mike from PA money. Okay. Cuz this guy had like at some
point this guy had like 5,000 subscribers or something.
Okay. I'm totally down for that. You get it? Yeah. Yeah. I don't
want to talk [__] on it, but
why doesn't it feel like people can quite get to the
levels that Raj Roy royale could? Dude, I question so much. I
miss
uh
it feel Yeah. Oh, the quality of the people. It really is. [__]
man. It's It's just a lesser quality. Are you Are you talking
about the contestants or the hosts or both? Both. Yes. Raj is
a way better instigator than Stephen. I feel like Stephen just
like is itching to get involved because I feel like he likes
being a contestant. He just loves being there to argue and make
people look stupid. He doesn't likeing it. And
idiot. That guy's no way what he's doing. And then the contestants
are just way worse on average compared to like Raj days when
that was also before it was too saturated. The type of streamers
that are on kick now are not the type of people who have aspirations
in the in the field of like that. You know what I mean? They're
just like a bunch of zoomersh kids who want to make easy money,
get a gambling deal, and just be easy breezy, right? Not the
type of like that want to like claw and grind out their communities
the way like those type of people do. Cuz if you look at 99%
of the people that blew up from back then, they're all dead.
The only people that are still around or that have any sort of
No, the Raj Royale. No. Yes. Who got big from that? That still's
big rush. I mean, I don't know if anybody got big from that to
be honest except the host. Slicker went huge. Slicker was like
a three to five candy. I wouldn't count him as somebody who like
fell off like he just got big. Well, Bruce Dropov got dro I mean
he's he fell off. Bruce got big through the collaboration with
like your rage and uh or not the amp guys. I think I remember
he did. And that's also when he fell off was when he talked Kaisenat
and it just was like he Yeah, he [__] talked Kaisat
and he just like died overnight. Yeah, he died overnight. It
was an idiot. Like why would you do that? This stupid he was
averaging like 20k views and he dropped to like 5k like in a
week on your golden goose. Like what a dumbass. Mhm. Was such
a dumb move on his part. What did he say? I don't even know.
He was he was talking about the fact that uh cuz they were supposed
to go on a trip. I'm going to mess it up. I'm not even going
to repeat it. But um
when
uh he was he was just talking about how it was it was something
about a trip. Um is it a Japan trip by chance? I think I I don't
remember. It could have been Wolf Gang, but I I don't remember
necessarily.
And uh when when people confronted him about it, he was like,
"Yeah, you know what I'm saying? I'm real. I keep it real." And
like that, you know, you why? He didn't deny it. And and like
Kai said, "You you must be on medication or something like that.
You're going to say something to me one way and then behind my
back you talk." I think it was a moderator in in involved or
a edit somebody who does the editing or something. Weird. I can't
remember. Whatever it was, like Bruce reallyed up. What a dumbass.
Reallyed up. Like he had no reason. And it to me it was out of
jealousy. It could have, you know, it sound like it was something
out of jealousy that Bruce did. You know what I find super insane
is that Molina blew up from dating Destiny and now after that
that it did like she's still massive like you know still gets
a ton of viewers like her community. Way better than I thought.
Yeah. She had like it's like her community was has nothing to
do with this. Yeah. No, same. Well, let's be clear. She's a She's
still beautiful, guys. I mean, just because she's not with um
Stephen, I mean, she's all right. She's No, she's more than all
right. She's
Oh, be Okay. Yeah. I thought you were talking about looks explicitly.
Jeez Louise. I I thought you were like she's just like she's
a streamer. I thought that's what you were saying. No, she's
personable. I' I've sit and just sit at a couple of her streams
and she's very engaging with her chat and that's a really big
Oh, I agree. I'm not saying that she um she only had success,
but obviously being connect Destiny was like the the catalyst.
Yes. And then usually when you disconnect from the catalyst completely.
A lot of time the products of that catalyst fail. Not at all.
Because think about all the men that can say it's my turn. I
got a chance now. Really? No. What? No way. That's not her viewers,
though. That's not it at all.
No, because No, cuz she immediately started dating that skitso
kid from Sweden or whatever. I think she did kind of fall off
a little bit though. Like it's not massive. And I am surprised
that she held on to like as much as she did, but like she did
she stopped streaming. I think probably the falloff's from her
stopping streaming. Like she just got really sporadic with her
streams more than not being with Destiny. Wait, is she not streaming
anymore or is she still going or she's just like doesn't go consistent
at all? Like she's just got huge gaps in here. I think she's
more consistent right now, but like Yeah, I don't know. Even
this isn't terribly consistent in the past little while. Probably
trying to weather the storm ride it out a little bit. Yeah, that's
when you farm it the hardest, bro. I'd be live 24/7 right after
a big breakup. Dude, if she went live and she like she like put
something like um clearing everything up or like setting the
record straight in her title, she'd have like 10 viewers. Yeah.
Yeah, that'd be awesome. Like setting the record straight and
then just sit there with your legs kicked up for like eight hours
and collect that. What's Vader V doing? I miss her so much. Like
you met What do you mean you Wait, have you met her? I was in
love with this woman. Yeah, we had a she shows. What? Yes. Yeah.
Back in the day when we first found her. W because I remember
Do you do you know who Claw on Twitch is? Yeah. So Claw on Twitch
found her when she had like nothing like no viewers. She had
two viewers on streams and that's when I first met her and started
talking to her and
uh and then she blew up from doing the Rod shows and a mega.
God bless America. Was she anor
streamer um when she was she always has been she always has been.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. She uh times she she got she lost her me after
like weeks of talking because I made that joke, you know, like,
"Girl, you crazy. How do you just speak to girls?" Right? No
woman would ever freak out by this. But she lost her mental over
it. She's like, "Wes, I'm not insane. I'm not crazy. I don't
appreciate you saying like that. It's not funny." Blah blah blah
blah. And I didn't like go deep at all. I was like, "You crazy."
Just like cute, flirtatious type [__] And she lost
her mental over it. And then I had never talked to her again.
So that's when I realized she's insane. Gosh, I see. I see. I
see. God, she's so hot. Oh my god. I don't know. I I listen,
Wes. You know, I appreciate what you're saying here, but you'll
never ever get a sound bite of me saying that she's insane. Okay.
It'll never happen. Look at that picture, though. Which picture?
Can you just look at the picture I just linked to you in the
DMs? Oh, I can. Can you just look at that picture? Hold on. Hold
on. I Is this going to pop up on my main browser? I might have
to be defensive. No, it's it's not TOSS. It's Whoa. It's not
to
chat will love it. Chat will love it. Uh, listen. I need at least
one subscriber on kick to show this picture right now. I leaked
this woman's nudes on my stream. Wait, did you really? I accidentally
leaked her nudes on my stream. Yeah, I was really drunk one night
and I was I don't remember how, but um Wait, how did you get
them? From I told you we had a like a little thing. Oh, you Wait,
you and Invader? No. Stop. Stop. Stop. No, everything stops.
I swear I literally up until a few weeks ago, I still had them.
I saw on my phone recently and I did my great purge when I was
like, "Stop jerking off to" and I deleted everything. But I if
I went to our DMs on Twitter, which I can't access, I'm banned.
Uh they're all still in there for my mental health. I'm choosing
to not believe you. I I mean it for for the sake of my mental.
She's so I I have a policy about like not accepting friend requests
from women I've never talked to before on Discord cuz Yeah. like
Yeah. She's the She's the
accept all women and then I say who diss. You never know. Never
mind. Some freak [__] just want to show you a butthole.
Yeah. No, but that's usually what it is. And there's nothing
good that can come of that. Wes
uh quit being a gay and there's literally nothing good. Okay.
I'm on my own. Who cares? You just got to getting exposed. I'm
just going to make my money. I'm It's so cringe. It's not about
Hold on. It's not about getting exposed. I don't care about getting
exposed. Get your rocks off to chicks [__] wasting
time. It's just wasting time. Maximizing
money. Time is money. Yeah, you got to react to more content
for 4 hours. Also, I just Exactly, Wes. I got to be live. Okay.
waste attorney. I couldn't farm any money out of this, so I'll
just show the picture on screen. Okay, this is the picture Wes
was trying to show. Damn. Damn. Okay. Damn. One time I responded
there were comments and then I said I would live 10,000 lives
alone just is that like a summon but with come I think it was
on that picture I responded I would live 10,000 lives alone if
it meant I could live one life with you. And everyone was like
where do you get this from? That's such a smooth line. That's
how much I love that woman. She's so mad. Let's stick it for
Wait, is she like off of Twitter now or Yeah, doesn't even have
a doesn't do anything, dude. I don't very weirdly private person.
Like her all of her streams are very like robotic.
They're just like lazy kumbait.
Yeah, but she gets a lot of view, but she could easily network
her way up to being massive. Yeah, she doesn't want to. She's
come stop completely. She's fallen. Not falling off. She's She's
ized herself.
Whatever. She's just put a little bit. She's uh bosched herself.
There you go. Let's see here. Let's see where she is for viewers.
I mean, she's never ever like fallen off in terms of her raw
viewership. She's insanely hot. She never will till she gets
ugly. I don't think she will though, cuz I think she's like older
now. She's got the like I don't know what it is. She's got like
the face that I think she'll look young forever. like she'll
just kind of I think she's got the Asian face where they look
long young until 45 and then boom, they're 70. No, that will
happen. Yeah, that will happen. That will happen. I'm telling
you, she's going to have like the cute soccer mom look where
like you're at practice and you see her and you're like, damn.
I know that she's your mom, dude. But I'd hate your mom if I
Yeah,
mom's got it going. Jesus. What happened in September of 2022
for V? She put on a 100,000 subscribers in like a day. Wasn't
there one day where she put on like a crazy bunny suit or some
[__] like that and she started going full thim dump?
Because before I feel like she didn't use the and then all that
could have been the um
remember the the Call of Duty clip of her. Yeah, that was like
went mega massive. But like 100,000 in like a day. 100,000 in
a day. Show too. But yeah, a day is could be botted.
Mhm. I used to get botted followers on Twitter all the time like
in chunks of like thousands and I would never do it but randomly
they would it would happen. Could just be that. Look at this
guys. Look at this. Look at this graph going along. This graph's
just having like a normal day here. She has like this falloff.
This is probably where she argued with Pokemon where she lost
like what is it? Like a couple thousand subs and then she's like
going up going up and then she just in a day goes up a 100,000
subs. Wow. If only she's or 100,000 followers or whatever. Yeah,
crazy. Spiking right now, too. Look at the graph. Yeah, she's
she's going up cuz she gets banned. She's just like, dude, Twitch
is so insane that she like she puts on an insane outfit. She
gets banned. She gets a ton of press for it. She's on LSF. Oh,
Invader V banned for the fifth time. And everybody's like, "Yeah,
link the clip. Link the clip. Link the clip." Right. How is that?
I don't know. I've never seen that. How are How are toos violations
the best way to advertise? How do you run a platform like that?
How do you run a platform like that? She probably learned that
from Amar because she was famous for doing that. Yeah. Wait,
what happened? It works extremely well for women. She just got
married and had a kid.
She used to be my number one bro. That woman. Wait, who is that?
Christ. You
I literally didn't I didn't hear what you said. I know who ST
Peach is. I Are you kidding me? I would sacrifice tree of life
like to Satan to that woman in like 2018, dude. Wes has like
a fantasy list and he had like the list of atrocities he commit
for each one of them. This one you noticed. Holy [__]
This one's
got to have your list. Like you got to have your priorities straight.
Slavery for this one. What else we got here? A list of worst
things that you can do to somebody. And it's always women that
you just have no connection with at all. So [__]
Well, I'm going to tell you something. For a moment, I was feeling
like brave and I was determined like, dude, I don't know how
I'm going to do it, but I could I could r up invader B. She's
risable. You're insane. No, she's not. She's a She won. Maybe
not now, but I got in early, dude. I got when the stock was cheap.
Oh, yeah. You got before her ego was inflated to death, right?
I'm sure I got in early, bro. I could have been the one. I'm
If she has an ego, why I feel like I feel like there's no indication
she has like a massive ego. Well, as a woman for being her getting
her stroke for being a so hot every day is what I mean. Oh, sure.
You know, you need a [__] with like self-confidence
issues who just happens to be super hot.
You need a with bulimia. You need like the female Wes but the
one who lost the weight, right? Exactly. She still has all the
body image issues from from being overweight. Nice of you to
say because you you're you're recognizing that I'm extremely
attractive, just obese. Uh that's actually true though. Yeah,
I can I can tell. I can tell. I know. I know. Yeah, I'll be real
with you. I I Can somebody Oh, never mind. Never mind. I found
them. I found I was like, "How do I unban Darius?" But I just
I found them now. You banned Darius? I mean, I didn't ban I'm
sorry. Block. How do I um I I You blocked Darius. That's bad.
Yeah. Yeah. What did he do? I'm blocking him now. No,
he's that type, bro. There just a new girl will appear in the
Destiny verse and within 48 hours Destiny is or Darius is in
their DMs. Yeah, 100%. Every time. I get it though. Guy's got
a hammer. Does he? Yes. I saw a video so his ex-girlfriend I
saw I used to had a thing with her for a little bit like not
a real thing but like a
video where she pukes on him. No, I saw a video of her getting
absolutely split in half by this massive
and I immediately was like gh like she's like a 100 pounds getting
just literally torn in half by like a monster and then I come
to find out the other night it's Darius's Darius. How'd you find
out? Did someone did he tell you? Oh yeah, that one. I was at
his house and he was like, "Bro, yeah, that one that you said
makes sense because they dated for a long time." He's like, "Yeah,
she never shot Only Fans content with him but me." I'm assuming
it's his. I never seen it. I've never seen you have no idea.
He's got a goddamn cannon, which is why women turn into psychopaths
because he's a he's a right kid. He's He's just like a He's a
classic old Rizzler type. You know what I mean? He's not rich
with like the brain fungus from when they go in his room. No,
it's a fungus fungus, bro. He is a gremlin, though. He lives
like a gremlin. Tree, what? I'm trying to I'm looking at the
vods here. What eye color do you have? It's hard here with this.
How about you shut stop talking about woman like that
business what her eye colors are. I'm being paid to draw. Okay.
Wes that's professional. Okay. They're green and beautiful.
Green and beautiful. Thank you very much tree. No they're Hazel.
[__] Hazel. Thank you. Thank you. I'll be honest.
I wasn't looking at your eyes anyway. I was looking at your Yeah.
Like when do you look someone in their eyes? Never.
When they're a man. That's when they deserve the respect. Okay,
I'm kidding. I'm not I'm not a bigot. I'm not a misogynist. I
love women. Base. Okay, guys. I think we're on like the 5 to
10 minute warning here. I told Darius if he goes live, I'll I'll
rate him. So, you guys got anything you want to get out for messages
here real quick? Uh you guys don't have to leave if you don't
want to. I'm just I'm just saying. Okay. Well, Wes is out. He
uh he took that personally.
I wanted to ask him about going over to Darius's place, but he
just left. Oh. Um, you guys got anything else you wanted to get
out on stream? I want to say thank you for having me. I don't
I know I don't come often here, but um, when I saw I I ended
my stream early because I did my interview with Jasmine, so I
didn't have a long stream. So, when I saw that she was going
to talk about Lauren, I was like, "Oh, yeah. Let me get in on
this." So,
know I had to get in on her. I can't stand that. I can't stand
that at all. So, yeah. Hell yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, we'll see
how it goes. I have a feeling the drama is not over, but yeah.
And if it isn't, I'll be back cuz I'm here. That's one people
I hate. You can count me to be right up in here looking at the
damn drama with you, Jay. Yeah. Well, babe. Oh, yeah. Always
always glad to have another point of view that agrees with me
completely. Thank you. Just love saying I told you so. or I was
right or I called it or whatever. This guy's the biggest I called
it I've ever You know who I learned that from Wolf Gang? I learned
that from uh your buddy Hark Dan. No. Oh, from Dan. Dan Dan is
the best at that. Okay. Yeah. But didn't Dan just throw at the
wall and sometimes it sticks, but he'll forget the parts where
he misses. Okay. Yeah, that's based. Okay. If you if you throw
at the wall and you let and sticks and then all you do is talk
about how it's stuck, people think you're just right. So based
true. But then you literally win. Yeah. As a character, I like
that. Okay. Well, also just if Darius is listening, you better
go live right away, buddy. Got to go live. Is he not Is he not
live? He's not. He said he was going live. Well, if he's not
live, then he doesn't get it. Then give it to someone else. That
would teach him a lesson. He needs to learn. Well, I don't He
can like do his loading screen and stuff, too. So, that's why
I told him I'd host him, but then he's like AFK. Then he doesn't
get the host. He doesn't get the host. Over. I want I want him
to get the host. He's just uh I don't know what he's doing. You
love him. Say you love him. Just say he must be punished. No.
Holy [__] J's on a different mindset than you are
right now. Okay. It's the only way he's going to learn. He's
a brat, bro. Time to He is a brat, though. Break the brat. Okay.
Hold up. Tre's interview with Jasmine.
Oh my god. We had such a good time. Wait, Jasmine's actually
No, not that one. No, no, no, no, no. Go to There you go. Yeah,
that one right there.
This uh this thumbnail is going to get you a lot of views here,
Tree. It's a good choice of thumbnail.
Jasmine is dominant. Congratulations. I love that picture of
her. I live when I see it on YouTube. Okay. I'll probably end
up watching at least some of this at some point.
Okay. And and I I correct the spelling. Somebody told me like
10 minutes in that I I I misspelled spelling and I I I corrected
it on on the stream. So change scene. Oh, you guys didn't see
the thumbnail. Well, this is the video, but this was the thumbnail.
That was the thumbnail. I think that's going to be a winning
thumbnail. Okay, I like it. Yes. Cannot believe it, dude. That's
insane. All right. Oh, guys, last chance. By the way, if you
wanted to support us financially, you know, you could send a
super chat on YouTube. Streamlabs donations. the bot spams the
link every once in a while. Um, you can become a member on YouTube
or you can subscribe on kick. If you can't support monetarily,
that's okay. If you could just like the stream, follow on kick
or subscribe on YouTube, that helps us out, too. So, thank you
very much. That's me plugging. Okay.
Yeah. Right. How do I send you money without you getting my name?
Uh, you could donate subs on Kick Porter Beller and then Kick
and Well, technically I think Stripe has your name, but Stripe
can have your name. Miller, they probably got your name anyway.
That's true. Yeah, that's true. If you if you do do subscribers,
they'll
know your information is passed on. But you have Stream Labs,
don't you? Yeah, I have Streamlabs. Yeah. So, they could do it
through Streamlabs. They can, but if they do it through PayPal,
I'll get their PayPal information. Oh, yeah. True. Most people,
which for most people does have their name on it. So, yo, MK
is live. Merk is live, but we're going to host Darius, guys.
And he just went live. Is he gonna But he's going to sit in his
loading screen, too. Oh, whatever. This guy's a dumb dumb. True.
But you love that dum dum.
Sometimes it's hard to stay mad at him. Sometimes sometimes to
love, but he's harder to hate.
Yeah.
Go. See who's up on YouTube.
Is up on YouTube. Throw him. I don't know how long he's going
to stream for, but okay guys, I got the host set up and that's
it for us. Uh, any final words for Tree or Wolf Gand? Any final
words? Goodbye, chat. It was nice talking with you. And DGG,
I'm going to uh chat. I'm going to I haven't popped into your
chat in a long time, so I probably would do so either this weekend
or next week. I try to come in there twice a year.
Uh, as for me, um, I am love I'm in love with doing these little
avatars. If people are interested, let me know. You can tag me
on DG chat. You can find me on Distle Discord. Dragon Dogma comes
out in a couple hours. So, I hope you guys enjoy. Just get on
that, whoever wants it. And there you go. That's it. Oh, and
actually, one last thing before I go. If I said some very nasty
things to people tonight, I was just grumpy and I had a bad day,
okay? But I love you guys and don't worry, everything's okay.
Check my Discord to find the wolf gang slurs. Okay, sounds good.
Okay guys, uh thank you very much for watching tonight. Um we'll
be back tomorrow. I think tomorrow we're going to probably watch
and react to that Destiny Jordan Peterson conversation. I think
that's supposed to be out tomorrow. So looking forward to that.
Nice. All right. So I love you guys and we will see you all tomorrow.
We're hosting out the Darius. Have a good night. Good night.